bonsoir
la séance est ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion en
nouvelle lecture du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 à 2027 et pour
commencer cette séance qui sera pleine
de surprises nous l'imaginons la parole
est au ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
ministre cher Thomas Cazenave je suis
très heureux de vous retrouver pour
cette première séance d'examen de la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 à 2027 qui inaugure
sans doute beaucoup d'autres séances
peut-être similaires peut-être pas ça
dépendra de nos travaux en tout cas
aujourd'hui est un jour important pour
nos finances publiques puisque nous
avons présenté ce matin avec Thomas
Cazenave le projet de loi de finances
pour 2024 et que nous sommes amenés ce
soir à nous prononcer sur le projet de
loi de programmation des finances
publiques 2023 2027
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire en
commission ce texte est indispensable à
la crédibilité budgétaire de la nation
française et je tiens à remercier texte
qui a l'air de passionné des bicycles je
tiens à remercier les trois groupes de
la majorité Renaissance démocrate
horizon qui sont les seuls à avoir eu le
courage de voter pour le rétablissement
de nos finances publiques pour le
désendettement de la France et pour la
réduction de nos défis
ce texte est aussi fondamental pour
notre crédibilité par rapport au marché
quand nous sommes endettés quand nous
devons financer un déficit budgétaire et
que les taux d'intérêt dépassent les 3%
que la charge d'intérêt de la dette
atteint 74 milliards d'euros en 2027 il
me paraît responsable d'avoir un texte
qui fixe un câble de réduction de
déficit et de la dette enfin fondamental
pour notre crédibilité par rapport aux
autres États de la zone euro qui tousse
ont déjà adopté une trajectoire
pluriannuelle de réduction de leur dette
et de leur déficit
enfin chacun le sait et certains d'entre
vous l'ont dit pendant les débats en
commission de ce texte dépend le
décaissement de deux aides européennes
de 10,3 et de 7,5 milliards d'euros que
nous devrions recevoir avant la fin 2023
et en 2024 et je veux être clair avec la
représentation nationale sans loi de
programmation des finances publiques il
n'y aura pas de décaissement que chacun
prenne donc ses responsabilités
pour conforter notre crédibilité cette
loi de programmation fixe des objectifs
clairs pour 2027 retournez sous les 3%
de déficit public à 2,7 exactement
accélérer le désendettement pour revenir
à 108,1% de dettes publiques et réduire
le taux de prélèvement obligatoire d'un
point de 45,4 à 44,4 points
c'est toi le programmation repose
également sur des choix politiques forts
nous ne voulons pas de réduction de la
dépense publique ou de désendettement
par l'austérité nous ne voulons pas
tailler dans la dépense publique à
l'aveugle nous voulons que cette
réduction de la dette et que cette
réduction de déficit soit d'abord le
fruit de la croissance et de la
prospérité retrouvée de notre pays la
croissance elle est là 1% en 2023 1,4%
prévu en 2024 ce niveau de croissance
est un des plus élevé de la zone euro
elle nous permettra de réduire notre
dette d'ici 2027 et mesdames et
messieurs les députés de la majorité est
le résultat de la politique économique
que vous avez soutenue avec constance
depuis maintenant plus de 6 ans
pour accélérer cette croissance et la
renforcer encore dans les années à venir
il faut investir investir dans
l'industrie investir dans les nouvelles
technologies dans l'intelligence
artificielle dans la transition
écologique pour suivre le séchage de
l'épargne privé pour financer cette
transition écologique pas uniquement sur
fonds publics mais également sur fond
privé
renforcer la croissance cela suppose
aussi améliorer notre productivité car
la grande difficulté européenne
désormais la grande difficulté de la
zone euro aujourd'hui est d'avoir des
niveaux de croissance significativement
inférieur à ceux des États-Unis et des
pays asiatiques tout simplement parce
que la zone euro a perdu en productivité
et que nous devons investir davantage
dans l'éducation la formation la
qualification de nos salariés la grande
question économique des décennies à
venir sera la question éducative c'est
elle qui nous donnera de la productivité
c'est elle qui nous permettra d'avoir
des meilleurs salaires c'est elle qui
permettra de relever le niveau de vie de
chacun et chacune de nos compatriotes
en deuxième lieu le rétablissement des
finances publiques va reposer sur des
réformes de structures je le dis là
aussi à tous ceux qui nous reprochent de
ne pas être assez ambitieux dans le
rétablissement des finances publiques
pas assez ambitieux dans la trajectoire
de dette mais qui de l'autre côté toute
cohérence oubliée ont refusé de voter la
réforme de l'assurance chômage ou
refuser de voter la réforme des
retraites qui a L2 représente en cumulé
près de 25 milliards d'euros d'économies
d'ici 2027 il n'y a pas de
désendettement sans réforme de structure
il n'y a pas de désendettement sans
réforme de l'assurance chômage il n'y a
pas de désendettement sans réforme des
retraites qui augmente le taux d'emploi
de nos compatriotes et qui permet donc
de financer notre croissance
je le redis pas de rétablissement des
finances publiques pas de désendettement
sans régler la question des retraites
qui représentent je le rappelle 14% de
la dépense publique totale dans notre
pays et pour tous ceux qui
souhaiteraient aller plus loin je veux
dire une nouvelle fois cette tribune
comme je l'ai fait en commission que je
suis prêt à aller plus loin sur
l'ensemble des sujets de réforme de
structure je suis prêt à regarder avec
vous ce qui est envisageable de faire
sur la réforme d'assurance chômage je
suis prêt à regarder avec vous comment
est-ce qu'on redéfinit le périmètre de
l'État comment est-ce qu'on rend la
dépense sociale plus efficace au service
de nos compatriotes ce sont ces réformes
de structures qui permettent de réduire
de manière responsable la dette et les
déficits
contre 0,3% par an pour les
collectivités 0,9 pour l'État 03 pour
les collectivités locales c'est l'État
qui porte la plus grande partie de cet
effort
enfin ces réformes de structure doivent
accompagner de revues des dépenses les
revues de dépenses que nous avons déjà
engagé en 2023 nous ont permis
d'identifier 2 milliards d'euros
d'économies à terme sur le Pinel un
milliard sur les opérateurs de l'État et
600 millions d'euros chez les coûts des
apprentis nous sommes déterminés à
poursuivre sur une base annuelle cette
revue de dépenses publiques à raison de
15 revues de dépenses publiques par an
pour identifier l'ensemble des économies
possibles sur la dépense de l'État pour
la rendre plus efficace à l'horizon 2027
nous avons aussi engagé avec l'accord
des professions concernées la conversion
notre fiscalité d'une fiscalité brune
vers une fiscalité verte avec un
principe fondamental toutes les recettes
fiscales supplémentaires résultant de
l'augmentation de la fiscalité sur les
énergies fossiles iront à la transition
écologique pour les professions
concernées quand nous décidons
d'augmenter les assises sur le gazole
non routier pour les agriculteurs nous
le faisons progressivement 2,8 centimes
par an nous le faisons en les
accompagnant et nous le faisons en
reversant l'intégralité des recettes aux
agriculteurs pour qu'ils transforment
leurs exploitations je ne crois pas une
écologie punitive je ne crois pas une
écologie du diktat je crois une écologie
qui accompagne qui dialogue et qui
permet à chacun d'avoir des solutions
rencontrent
même chose pour les entrepreneurs des
travaux publics
même chose pour les entrepreneurs de
travaux publics nous refusons la
brutalité nous refusons les diktates en
matière de transition écologique et nous
les accompagnons en augmentant la
fiscalité sur les entreurs des travaux
publics de 5,99 centimes d'euros par an
jusqu'en 2030 progressivement en
reversant toutes les recettes pour
qu'ils puissent acheter des engins de
chantier électrique décarbonés leur
activité et avoir accès à une filière de
bio-carburant c'est cette méthode dans
la concertation dans le dialogue dans
l'accompagnement et dans la
prévisibilité pour les professions qui
permettra de rendre la transition
écologique acceptable pour tous les
secteurs économiques
enfin le principe cardinal au-delà de
ces réformes de structure de
l'accompagnement des secteurs concernés
de la croissance que nous avons retrouvé
du taux d'emploi qui est aujourd'hui et
ça doit être une fierté pour notre
majorité le plus élevé qui est jamais
existé en France depuis que nous
calculons le taux d'emploi 74% des
personnes qui ont un travail entre 25 et
65 ans c'est votre résultat c'est votre
succès c'est votre politique c'est votre
détermination appliquer une politique de
l'offre qui soutient les entrepreneurs
qui baissent les impôts et qui
récompense le travail le travail
restera le cœur d'autres politiques et
nous permettra de parvenir aux
désendettement et au rétablissement des
finances publiques cela suppose des
éléments de soutien concrets au travail
c'est ce que nous faisons avec la baisse
des impôts que nous avons engagé depuis
2017 et que nous poursuivrons en 2025
c'est ce qui passe également par la mise
en place de l'indemnité carbu rant
travailleur pour accompagner toutes les
personnes qui travaillent et qui sera
ciblées sur les travailleurs les plus
modestes et c'est évidemment l'objet de
la grande conférence sociale qu'a voulu
le président de la République qui devra
aboutir à des avancées concrètes en
matière de rémunération
j'entends les cris sur cette partie là
de l'hémicycle mais je rappelle que vous
vous aviez proposé de supprimer tous les
allègements de charge sur les heures
supplémentaires pour les personnes qui
travaillent davantage nous n'avons pas
de leçon à recevoir de votre part en
matière de rémunération du travailleur
alors que nous avons développé
l'intéressement développer la
participation mise en place sa prime
défiscalisée et que nous au moins cher
collègues sont aux salariés aux
personnes qui travaillent le fruit de
leur travail et le fruit de leur
engagement notre politique récompense le
travail votre politique vole les
travailleurs c'est toute la différence
en compte
tous nos compatriotes voient
parfaitement il suffit d'écouter les
criques nous venons d'entendre le moment
de grandes confusions dans lequel nous
sommes qu'il y ait principalement à la
période d'inflation la plus élevée que
nous connaissions depuis les années 70
cette confusion a des raisons profondes
qui sont liées aux inquiétudes
économiques aux inquiétudes climatiques
aux inquiétudes géopolitiques et bien
dans le domaine des finances publiques
vous avez vous tous ici mesdames et
messieurs et députés l'occasion unique
de mettre un peu de lumière dans cette
confusion de fixer un cap clair une
méthode pour y parvenir et des
engagements chiffrés cette loi de
programmation des finances publiques est
indispensable pour la France est une
nécessité pour nos compatriotes et elle
est un garde-fou elle est un garde-fou
contre l'explosion de la dette que
certains voudraient engager et que nous
amèneraient à dépenser des sommes
totalement excessives pour la charge de
la dette
elle est un garde-fou contre cette
supposée fatalité qui nous empêche de
rétablir les finances publiques depuis
30 ans y compris quand la situation
s'améliore est un garde-fou contre cette
propension nationale irrésistible à la
dépense publique sans considération de
son utilité ou de son efficacité
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
de la majorité vous pouvez être fiers
d'être les seuls dans cette hémicycle
avoir pris vos responsabilités avoir
voté pour le désendettement de la France
pour la réduction de la dépense publique
et pour le renforcement de l'efficacité
de l'action de l'État
merci
merci monsieur le ministre nous
accueillons maintenant dans le silence
le ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics Monsieur Thomas Cazenave
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur messieurs
les ministères Bruno cher Franck
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances monsieur le rapporteur
général mesdames et messieurs les
députés le texte que nous aujourd'hui et
celui qui a été établi par la commission
des finances après plusieurs heures
d'échanges très riches lundi soir qui
ont permis de discuter en détail non
seulement chaque article mais aussi
l'apporter et le sens de ce texte qui
vise à donner un cap financier à notre
nation le texte qui est issu de ces
travaux est un texte de grande qualité
vous le savez ce projet de loi traduit
le cap que nous avons fixé ramener le
déficit public sous la barre des 3%
d'ici la fin du quinquennat
ce projet de loi est pleinement cohérent
avec le programme de stabilité que nous
avons présenté en avril dernier je tiens
à insister sur ce point la France a
besoin d'une trajectoire d'un CAP pour
ces finances publiques la nouvelle
trajectoire doit nous permettre de tenir
nos comptes aujourd'hui comme demain il
parvenir supposent de partager un même
sentiment de responsabilité
responsabilité responsabilité vis-à-vis
de notre pays de sa crédibilité de sa
capacité d'action et de son indépendance
il parvenir suppose aussi de répartir
les forts entre l'ensemble des
administrations publiques l'État et ses
opérateurs la sécurité sociale et les
collectivités territoriales
mon premier message est clair ce projet
de loi de programmation des finances
publiques est un élément central de
notre crédibilité pas celle du
gouvernement celle de notre nation
crédibilité vis-à-vis des Français tout
d'abord qui ont besoin de connaître
notre chemin celui d'un retour à la
normale après des années de crise qui
ont besoin qui ont besoin de savoir
comment nous allons financer comment
nous allons financer nos services
publics et les investissements dans
l'avenir dont nous avons tant besoin
crédibilité aussi vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires européens puisque nous
traduisons dans ce texte les objectifs
fixés dans le programme de stabilité ce
sont deux versements du plan de relance
européen qui sont en jeu et qui sont
conditionnés à l'adoption d'une loi de
programmation pluriannuel
inversement un versement de 10 milliards
d'euros qui doit intervenir cette année
un versement de 8 milliards d'euros qui
doit intervenir l'année prochaine nous
n'avons parlé en détail en commission
des finances certains d'entre vous
avaient des doutes nous avons apporté je
crois par écrit et oralement les
précisions demandées qui permettent
d'affirmer que sans loi de programmation
c'est fond ne nous serons pas versés
alors même alors même que nous comptons
sur ces fonds et qu'ils sont intégrés à
notre trajectoire et je le rappelle et
je le rappelle
ne nous laissons pas aller à de faux
débats ce n'est pas une condition
imposée à la France par l'Union
européenne ce sont des engagements que
nous avons pris volontairement
crédibilité crédibilité aussi vis-à-vis
des investisseurs qui achètent dans
notre dette dans un contexte de remontée
des taux d'intérêt en quelques mois nos
taux d'emprunt sont passés de taux quasi
nul à des taux supérieurs à 3% sur nos
obligations en 2027 la charge de la
dette devrait atteindre 74 milliards
d'euros plus que le budget consacré à
l'éducation nationale donc je pose la
question quel serait le signal envoyé si
nous n'avions pas de loi de
programmation
en matière de crédibilité j'ai bien
conscience que l'eau conseille aux
finances publiques a formulé plusieurs
réserves
je ferai une remarque sur l'hypothèse de
croissance potentielle à
1,35%. jusqu'en 2027 notre estimation
est proche de prévisions que font les
instituts qui tiennent compte de nos
réformes comme le FMI ou le FCE car oui
notre prévision de croissance
potentielle s'appuie sur les réformes
structurelles que nous mettons en oeuvre
la réforme des retraites celle de
l'assurance chômage ou de France travail
la réforme du lycée professionnel la
réforme de l'apprentissage la mise en
place du service public de la petite
enfance la mise en oeuvre des plans
d'investissement et la baisse des impôts
de production
mon deuxième message porte sur le rythme
le rythme de rétablissement de nos
finances publiques nous le savons la
consolidation trop rapide casse la
croissance et génère en réalité plus de
dépenses qu'elle ne génère d’économie
c'est pour cela que nous assumons dans
cette trajectoire une stratégie de
réduction progressive du déficit qui
permet de poursuivre les investissements
dans les services publics dans la
transition écologique et les baisses
d'impôts c'est ma réponse à ceux qui
dénoncent une stratégie d'austérité qui
n'a jamais été la nôtre
par rapport au texte qui vous a été
présenté il y a un an nous avons
cependant une trajectoire de retour sous
les 3% de déficit public légèrement plus
rapide nous visons 2,7% en 2027 au lieu
de 2,9% il y a un an la France ne peut
pas se démarquer par rapport à ses
partenaires européens je le rappelle
nous pourrions être le dernier pays
européen dans le déficit repasse sous la
barre des 3% pour y parvenir nous
faisons fortement baisser la part des
dépenses publiques dans le PIB même si
elle continueront à croître en euros et
nous stabilisons à 44,4 % la part des
prélèvements obligatoires alors cela
implique de réaliser 12 milliards
d'euros d'économie à partir de 2025
répartis à part égale entre l'État et
ses opérateurs et la sécurité sociale
je le dis c'est un effort très important
nous assumons que ces économies doivent
être documentées cela implique aussi que
les collectivités territoriales tout en
continuant à investir maîtrise leur
dépenses mais nous ne reviendrons pas à
l'idée d'un mécanisme d'incitation tel
qui figurait dans la première mouture de
la loi il n'y aura pas de carbis nous
parviendrons à réaliser ces économies
par une démarche renouvelée de revues de
dépenses une démarche ouverte associant
les parties prenantes nous avons voulu
que ces nouvelles revues de dépenses
soient portées au plus haut niveau et
par tous car la dette publique et
l'affaire de tous état opérateur
collectivité sécurité sociale
dans le cadre du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques locales nous sommes
convenus de lancer de nouvelles revues
de dépenses je pense notamment à celle
sur l'évaluation du coût de
l'enchevêtrement des compétences et des
responsabilités sur le territoire entre
l'État et les agences et les
collectivités locales
le gouvernement déposera par ailleurs un
amendement pour rétablir l'article 16 du
projet de loi qui définit un objectif
d'évolution de la dépense locale
nous la déposerons dans sa version
enrichie dans sa version enrichie par
l'amendement de Véronique louvagi du
groupe LR et qui rejoint les travaux des
groupes lyotes écologistes et
socialistes seront exclus du périmètre
certaines dépenses les dépenses
allocations individuelles de solidarité
mais aussi suite au débat parlementaire
les dépenses relatives à l'aide sociale
à l'enfance
nous intégrons davantage d'économies à
notre trajectoire mais nous ne
conservons pas la trajectoire issue du
Sénat que nous ne jugeons ni réaliste ni
souhaitable nous le savons la
consolidation trop rapide casse la
croissance c'est pour cela que nous
assumons dans cette trajectoire une
stratégie de réduction progressive du
déficit public
au-delà de ce nouvel équilibre qui vous
est proposé par la réduction de nos
déficits les amendements qui ont été
adoptés en commission des finances lundi
ont permis d'actualiser notre
trajectoire un an après le premier
examen les prévisions d'inflation
étaient actualisées par ailleurs après
un an de travail supplémentaire les
trajectoires financières des différentes
politiques publiques et les enveloppes
des caisses de sécurité sociale ont
elles aussi étaient actualisées le
gouvernement a donc proposé une série
d'amendements qui mettent le texte et le
rapport de la loi de programmation en
cohérence avec la vision que nous avons
aujourd'hui de notre trajectoire
économique et financière ils sont
intégrés au texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui
ce nouvel examen qui intervient un an
après le premier tir enfin les
conclusions d'une année de travaux du
secretariat général pour la
planification écologique je crois que
nous devons partager le double défi qui
est devant nous nous avons deux dettes
une dette publique et une dette
écologique
l'actualisation de la LPFP que nous
proposons aujourd'hui donne une vision
actualisée des crédits de l'État
consacré à la transition écologique en
cohérence avec l'investissement
supplémentaire de 10 milliards d'euros
annoncé par le président de la
République et la première ministre se
traduisant par une hausse historique des
crédits de paiement de 7 milliards
d'euros en 2024 elle consacre aussi
l'obligation de faire baisser le poids
des défenses des dépenses néfastes à
l'environnement
vous avez par ailleurs adopter un
amendement déposé à l'initiative de
plusieurs députés notamment David Amiel
et Pierre Cazeneuve qui prévoit
l'établissement d'une stratégie
plurielle
d'une stratégie plus réelle des
financements de la transition écologique
cet amendement de la majorité rejoint
plusieurs amendements qui ont été
déposés par l'opposition mais ce n'est
pas une surprise car cette demande c'est
demande vous êtes il est aujourd'hui
satisfait vous voyez une demande de
visibilité pluriannuelle a été exprimée
par tous les groupes lors des dialogues
de Bercy nous y sommes très favorables
parce que nous devons à nos concitoyens
une visibilité sur les moyens consacrer
à la résorption de notre dette
écologique vous avez également adopté un
amendement déposé par Lisa belouko du
groupe écologiste qui renforce
l'exigence que nous nous fixons en
matière de réduction du poids des
dépenses publiques néfastes à
l'environnement j'ai donné un avis
favorable et je la remercie pour cet
enrichissement du texte
ce que je souhaite vous dire enfin c'est
que la loi de programmation est aussi un
engagement envers le Parlement construit
avec le Parlement ne l'oublions pas ce
texte est avant tout pour le Parlement
pour partager un cap pour mieux piloter
les finances publiques pour s'assurer
que les lois de finance annuelles
s'inscrivent en cohérence avec la
trajectoire que le gouvernement propose
c'est pour cela que j'ai donné un avis
favorable à 15 amendements
parlementaires 13
de la majorité 3 des oppositions qui
permettent notamment
3 et 12 et de mieux encadrer les
pratiques financières comme les niches
fiscales et sociales et de mieux et de
mieux et de mieux informer le Parlement
ces amendements ces amendements émane
ses amendes c'est chers
ces amendements émanent de la majorité
portée notamment par le rapporteur
général
porté par le rapporteur général
Jean-René Cazeneuve par Mathieu Lefebvre
par Daniel la baronne mais aussi de
l'opposition notamment un amendement de
Philippe Brun pour le groupe socialiste
qui pose le principe que toutes les
nouvelles niches fiscales soient bornée
dans le temps
je crois au dialogue je hais le
sectarisme
une bonne idée est une bonne idée quelle
que soit le banc quel que soit le banc
dont elle émane mes chers collègues
rappelons-nous aussi que depuis la
révision de la LOLF la portée de la loi
de programmation pluriannuelle a été
renforcée
une traduction concrète en est que le
gouvernement doit désormais justifier
devant l’eau conseil aux finances
publiques les éventuels écarts par
rapport à la trajectoire pluriannuelle
en amont du dépôt du projet loi de
finance donc pour dire les choses
simplement il me semblerait un peu
déroutant que le Parlement après avoir à
juste titre
œuvrer pour renforcer son pouvoir de
contrôle se prive d'un important
instrument de ce contrôle
mesdames et messieurs pour conclure le
texte que nous vous présentons est une
trajectoire et un texte enrichi un texte
enrichi par le travail parlementaire en
commission une trajectoire qui ramène le
déficit public sous la barre des 3% en
2027 et réduit le niveau des dépenses
publiques qui stabilise le taux de
prélèvement obligatoire de 2023 à 2027
et qui enfin finance les priorités des
Français je vous remercie pour votre
attention
bien nous allons passer dix minutes
maximum de notre temps avec le
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances de l'économie générale et du
contrôle budgétaire Jean René Cazeneuve
à qui je cède la parole
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances mes chers
collègues le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 à 2027 a été adopté
par notre commission des finances il y a
48 heures je me réjouis que la
mobilisation à la fois de la majorité
l'esprit de responsabilité est permis
cette adoption dans une version tenant
compte de la trajectoire pluriannuelle
proposée par le gouvernement je le
répète depuis un an et je continuerai à
le faire ce soir devant vous doté notre
pays du noix de programmation des
finances publiques et indispensable
il en va de la crédibilité budgétaire de
notre pays je l'ai rappelé en commission
des finances à cette tribune aux
différents partis de l'opposition dans
les médias partout nous avons besoin
pourquoi pourquoi
d'abord la loi de programmation des
finances publiques donne tout simplement
de la visibilité sur cinq ans à notre
administration à nos ministères à nos
concitoyens sur les grandes politiques
publiques de notre pays ensuite la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
constitue la référence obligée sur
laquelle Haut Conseil des finances
publiques s'appuie pour juger des écarts
constatés au titre de l'exécution
budgétaire chacun a pu noter que son
président Pierre Moscovici souligne
systématiquement la nécessité financière
et juridique de définir à court terme
une telle référence pour notre pays
si cette référence qui permet à notre
Parlement de contrôler l'action du
gouvernement à ce titre la loi de
programmation est essentielle à notre
vie démocratique ne nous privons pas
nous les parlementaires de cet outil
enfin chers collègues 18 milliards
d'euros de crédits européens sont
suspendus à votre vote à notre vote 18
milliards 18 milliards qui bénéficient
au plan de relance 18 milliards qui
bénéficient à nos écoles 18 milliards
qui permettent le verdissement de nos de
notre industrie 18 milliards dans le
cadre du plan de relance européen notre
pays a pris l'engagement
de s'appuyer sur la promulgation du mois
de programmation des finances publiques
alors je sais certains d'entre vous
mettent en doute cet argument le moins
qu'on puisse dire j'ai donc demandé très
récemment des précisions au gouvernement
qui m'a répondu je vous ai fait part de
cette réponse alors on peut
ergoter se faire spécialiste de
l'exégèse mais les mots de la Commission
européenne sont sans ambiguïté dans les
courriers qui nous ont été adressés pas
de loi de programmation pas de jalons
pas de versement c'est aussi simple que
ça je vous parle de 18 milliards mais en
réalité le manque à gagner est bien plus
élevé puisque l'absence de loi de
programmation fait peser un risque réel
et avéré de plus de 27 milliards je sais
vous ne respectez pas les institutions
le Conseil constitutionnel comme les
autres
j'entends dans les couloirs se promener
une petite musique il s'agirait
uniquement d'un risque
non du cercle c'est vrai chers collègues
chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
nous avons des choses à négocier avec
l'Europe comme eux moque de calcul du
prix de l'électricité ou les nouvelles
règles d'encadrement budgétaire ne
risque pas de réduire notre crédibilité
à zéro
cet enjeu crucial est imposé que dire du
contenu du contenu de ce texte le texte
adopté par notre commission des finances
et conforme au programme de stabilité
présenté par le gouvernement
à la Commission européenne en avril 2033
la trajectoire proposée par le
gouvernement conforte le nécessaire et
fort de maîtrise de nos finances
publiques que nous avons entrepris qu'il
faut continuer à déployer et qui
constitue notre priorité et nous engage
sur une trajectoire avec un déficit de
2,7 % en 2027 afficher cette trajectoire
et la tenir c'est obligatoire pour
maîtriser les taux et la gestion de
notre dette je tiens tout de même je le
président est-ce que ce qui aboie
pourrait s'arrêter ou est-ce que c'est
pas où est-ce que je rêve alors monsieur
le rapporteur général chacun va faire
son boulot ce soir je vous laisse
continuer votre discours je vais faire
le mien et les députés
de la charge de la dette elle passe de
38 milliards cette année un peu plus de
74 milliards en 2027 cela doit nous
interroger collectivement si la dette
est un moyen de financement évidemment
légitime à laquelle nous en avons
recours en France pour protéger nos
concitoyens elle pose aujourd'hui des
questions de souveraineté vis-à-vis des
marchés financiers
j'entends ce qui affirme que nous devons
absolument faire des économies et
prétendre que la maîtrise des finances
publiques est dans l'ADN de leur groupe
politique associe et bien je leur dis
voter la loi de programmation des
finances publiques qui vous est présenté
aujourd'hui à ceux qui prétendent en fin
de compte
que ce n'est pas grave qu'on verra
demain je leur dis que si nous ne le
faisons pas
ce sont nos enfants et nos
petits-enfants qui devront payer la
dette financière et la dette écologique
que nous l'aiderons dans la loi de
programmation que nous allons examiner
le gouvernement propose une cible plus
ambitieuse de maîtrise de notre seul
public en 2027 à 2,7% contre 2,9% de la
loi initiale je me félicite de cet
effort supplémentaire alors augmenter
les prélèvements obligatoires c'est à
dire des impôts n'est plus possible car
notre taux est le plus élevé du Monde ou
un des plus élevés du monde nous le
stabiliserons jusqu'en 2027 légèrement
au-dessus de 44%. c'est la croissance de
la dépense publique qui doit être
maîtrisée cela doit se traduire par un
effort collectif un effort d'abord de
l'État puisque ces dépenses doivent
diminuer en volume de 0,9% par an mais
un effort également des collectivités
territoriales de 0,3% par an qui est
moins importante je suis de qui ne pose
jamais jamais l'État et les
collectivités territoriales nous servons
ensemble les Français nous assurons
ensemble les services publics la France
est une République indivisible dotée
d'une organisation décentralisée c'est
l'article 1 de notre Constitution mais
si les taux se dégradent parce que nous
ne maîtrisons pas nos dépenses globales
il se dégradent pour l'État et pour les
collectivités territoriales sachons
avancer ensemble pour l'intérêt national
dans le respect des libertés des total
trajectoires plus ambitieuses et fort
accrue sur la dépense publique objectif
d'économie chiffrée et documenté
suppression de tout dispositif
d'encadrement des dépenses réelles de
fonctionnement des collectivités
territoriales je note que la trajectoire
proposée par le gouvernement tout comme
les moyens de la respecter se
rapprochent de la vision de la maîtrise
des finances publiques exposées par le
Sénat à l'automne 2020 j'ai la
conviction que nous pouvons encore
rapprocher nos points de vue mais la
trajectoire de nos finances publiques
est loin d'être le seul sujet du texte
d'autres avancées importantes sont à
considérer de nouveau dispositifs de
bornage et d'évaluation des dépenses
fiscales des dépenses sociales et des
aides aux entreprises le principe du
plafonnement de toute taxe affectée
l'encadrement de la fixation des
plafonds correspondant la définition
d'une trajectoire de baisse du poids
relatif des dépenses publiques
favorables à l'environnement surtout ces
sujets très importants notre commission
accompli un travail
substantiel en nouvelle lecture gratos
grâce aux propositions et maintenant de
la part de l'ensemble des spectres
politiques que je voudrais saluer les
contributions des uns et des autres je
voudrais également souligner une avancée
essentielle en commission des finances
et souhaitée par beaucoup ici dans cette
hémicy avec la loi de programmation nous
nous dotons d'une programmation plus
rien annuelle importante pour relever le
défi immense du financement de la
transition écologique après avoir défini
les besoins d'investissement
nécessaire pour respecter notre notre
objectif de baisse des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre après avoir décliné
secteur par secteur acteur par acteur
leur contribution respective après avoir
réparti dans le temps les efforts
nécessaires pour tenir compte de notre
capacité à monter en puissance l'état
s'engagera désormais sur son financement
sur une base pluriannuelle en conclusion
je veux tenter une dernière fois de vous
convaincre mes chers collègues
d'approuver ce texte et de doter notre
pays du noix de programmation des
finances publiques vous l'avez compris
il s'agit de respecter l'encadrement
constitutionnel organique les
communautaires d'une finance publique je
entends que c'est difficile de votre
côté garantir que notre pays puisse
bénéficier des fonds du plan de relance
européen à la mise en oeuvre duquel la
grandement contribué en juillet 2020 là
aussi je comprends que les 18 milliards
ne sont pas importants pour vous
mettre en place et développer des outils
de bonnes gestion financières et doter
d'autres Parlement d'outils de suivi et
de contrôle de notre gouvernement dans
cette hémicycle la gauche de cette
émission nous accuse de mener une
politique d'austérité et propose une
trajectoire qui augmenterait de 90
milliards les dépenses publiques l'autre
opposition nous reproche de faire de la
gabjib GTR et nous propose de réduire de
30 milliards les dépenses publiques à
horizon 2027 peut-on imaginer que ces
deux visions diamétralement opposées de
nos dépenses publiques puissent s'allier
pour faire échouer ce texte nous avons
ici une programmation équilibrée mais
ambitieuse je formule le vœu que le
souci de l'intérêt général conduit
certains groupes d'opposition à la
beauté
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues je vous le dis très
sincèrement vous avez pas faire ce petit
cirque toute la soirée le président
Coquerel va s'exprimer vous avez envie
de l'entendre dans le silence respecter
les intervenants chacun c'est ça la
démocratie chacun a le droit d'exprimer
non non mais le petit cirque là le
décompte à la fin c'est pas admissible
le président Coquerel vient s'exprimer
pour 5 minutes
pas deux fois dans la soirée ça
[Applaudissements]
bien monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
rapporteur général chers collègues après
un premier rejet c'est assemblée de se
prononcer une nouvelle fois sur le
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques
cette proposition a déjà été refusée en
raison d'une opposition non pas une
programmation au contraire mais à son
orientation c'est à dire l'application
du logique finalement comptable avant
tout comptable alors que l'élaboration
de ce budget devrait d'abord répondre
aux besoins des Françaises et des
Français
non il ne s'agit pas d'un texte
technique mais bien d'un projet
politique que je juge incompatible avec
les défis qui se présentent alors
comment obtenir une majorité
si aucune concession nouvelle n'est
accordée le Parlement est dans son rôle
et la responsabilité ne peut être
rejetée sur les oppositions
tenter de convaincre cette assemblée par
l'argument d'une injonction européenne
n'est pas raisonnable premièrement
d'après l'étude mon administration rien
ne permet aujourd'hui d'affirmer que
l'absence d'adoption serait un motif
seul de blocage des versements
deuxièmement en admettant que ce
gouvernement minoritaire estime
nécessaire de sécuriser du soja long
alors il restait libre de modifier sa
politique budgétaire pour trouver une
majorité
un nouveau recours au 49-3 n'était donc
pas une fatalité pourtant nous savons
que ce sera le cas c'est un constat
d'échec de l'exécutif et de la
démocratie parlementaire
comme en première lecture toute la
logique de cette loi repose sur des
prévisions du croissance objectivement
surévalués ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est le l'autorité du Conseil des
finances publiques plus 1,4 % en 2024
contre 0,9% pour la Banque de France de
même pour la période 2025 de 2027 les
hypothèses du gouvernement négligent les
conséquences de ses propres choix
politiques sur la croissance je voudrais
d'ailleurs rappeler que si effectivement
et les ministres le disent les
estimations de croissance ont été de 1%
en 2023 contre ce que pensait les
économies c'est peut-être dû au fait
qu'en France on a effectivement un
niveau plus important de dépenses
publiques en Allemagne qui est rentrée
en récession or vous allez couper les
feux de la croissance publique et de
cette dépense publique dans les années à
venir comme en première lecture le
gouvernement prévoit des baisses de
dépenses publiques qui seraient plus
fortes qu'on études sous la Cinquième
République après une réforme des
retraites une réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui font peser les efforts sur
les salariés les retraités les chômeurs
tous ceux qui déjà payent l'augmentation
de l'inflation
d'importantes économies seraient encore
demandé au delà de leur caractère
irréalistes ces réductions seraient
dangereuses 12 milliards d'économies de
dépenses publiques sont prévues à partir
de 2025 mais elle reste à ce jour à
documenter pour c'est peut-être la
preuve qu'au fond il est désormais
difficile de renier sur les besoins
fondamentaux logements outre-mer santé
social éducation etc
aujourd'hui non les moyens ne sont pas à
la hauteur des besoins je sais Thomas
cazena vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
que vous estimiez que les 7 milliards
qui vont être mis sur la table cette
année en réalité vont faire des petits
en termes de dépenses publiques dans les
le dans les dans les comment dire dans
les collectivités locales pardon la BPI
et autres moi je ne crois pas à cette à
cet état de fait tant que l'État ne
mettra pas davantage la main à la pâte
il n'y aura pas ces 34 milliards que le
rapport pizani ferry estime nécessaire
vous nous dites quelles sont nos
propositions vous voulez de nom en
termes d'économie si le gouvernement
tient vraiment à réduire les dépenses
qu'il commence avec les recettes dont il
se prisent 94 milliards d'euros de niche
fiscale ont été abandonnées en 2022
arrêtons de supprimer la CVAE arrêtons
de supprimer des impôts sur les sociétés
arrêtons de supprimer des recettes
fiscales dont la plupart ont été
accordées au plus riche il suffit pour
cela par exemple tout simplement de
rétablir l'impôt sur la solidarité
financière de taxer les sous les supers
profits responsables la partie de
l'inflation je rappelle que si les 150
milliardaires les plus riches en France
étaient soumis au barème de la peau sur
les revenus c'est 18 milliards qui
rentreraient dans les caisses de l'État
si vous le comme vous l'avez affirmé
Bruno maire l'argent facile c'est fini
du fait de l'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt allant arrêtons de le
distribuer gratuitement au plus riche je
me réjouis cependant que ces idées
progressent le gouvernement refusait
l'année dernière de reconnaître
l'existence du super profit aujourd'hui
l'envisage d'une contribution des
sociétés concernées d'autoroute la mise
en place d'un prélèvement exceptionnel
sur le patrimoine des contribuables les
plus riches et défendus par une par une
partie du camp majoritaire les prix de
transfert sont questionnés la
suppression des allègements de
cotisations patron n'est plus à tabou ni
même l'analyse des 200 milliards qui
sont donnés chaque année en sans
contrepartie aux entreprises et qui
constituent la dépense la plus
importante de l'État vous l'aurez
compris je termine là-dessus monsieur le
Président une autre programmation est
nécessaire à les possibles elle doit
permettre de construire des budgets qui
partent des besoins de la population
du vivant et de la planète c'est un
observation de cette seule règle que
s'apprécie leur qualité merci
merci
monsieur le président
vous voyez il y a pas besoin de faire de
décompte j'ai reçu du président Vallot
et des membres du groupe socialiste et
apparentés de notions de rejet préalable
qui était déposée en application de
l'article 91 alinéa 5 du règlement et
pour défendre celle-ci pour la présenter
je donne la parole à la présidente
Valérie rabot
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
la motion de rejet du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 à 2027 que je
défends aujourd'hui au nom du groupe
socialiste et apparenté et motivé par
trois raisons principales la première
monsieur les ministres c'est le chantage
inadmissible auquel vous vous a donné
depuis quelques jours autour du vote de
cette loi de programmation voici ce dont
il s'agit lorsque l'Union européenne a
déployé en 2020 des crédits pour la
reprise et la résilience dans le cas du
plan de relance européen elle a
conditionné le versement de ses crédits
à des critères et la grande nouveauté
c'est plutôt que d'imposer les mêmes
critères à tout le monde comme cela est
habituellement le cas elle a demandé aux
états de proposer leur propre critères
ce qui est une grande nouveauté
l'Allemagne c'est elle engagée annoncé
des projets liés à l'hydrogène en
investissant un milliard cinq d'euros
l'Espagne a proposé un plan ambitieux de
1,6 milliards d'euros pour favoriser
l'attractivité l'accessibilité du réseau
ferroviaire public l'Italie bien sûr que
c'est bien enfin a acté des
investissements importants visant à
réduire les inégalités et les
vulnérabilités sociales dans le pays de
votre côté messieurs les ministres sans
jamais en référer de quelques façons que
ce soit au Parlement
vous avez proposé en catimini à
Bruxelles que l'un des critères pour le
versement des crédits soit l'adoption et
l'entrée en vigueur d'une noix de
programmation des finances publiques
comme si comme si c'était une formalité
mais à l'automne 2022 les choses ne se
déroulent pas comme prévu vous soumettez
une première version de cette loi de
programmation au Parlement l'assemblée
la rejette par 349 voix à 243 avant que
la scène le Sénat ne l'a réécrivent
totalement et un an plus tard vous
retentez donc votre chance et là je dois
avoir que depuis quelques jours nous
assistons à un festival monsieur le
ministre Bruno Le Maire vous avez
déclaré devant la commission des
finances et je vais vous citer que vous
vouliez être clair avec la
représentation nationale sans droit de
programmation il n'y aura pas
d'équaissement des aides européennes
ajoutons même que nous devrions faire la
croix sur 18 milliards d'euros d'aide
qui sont nécessaires pour nos finances
publiques
monsieur le ministre cette situation
pourrait prêter à sourire si elle ne
traduisait pas de la part du
gouvernement un nouveau dévoiement du
Parlement et c'est le premier sens que
je donne à cette motion de rejet je veux
que vous respectiez le Parlement que
cela vous plaise ou non que cela vous
plaise ou non c'est une obligation
constitutionnelle que vous avez tendance
à oublier un peu trop souvent le
gouvernement français et le seul à avoir
proposé à Bruxelles comme critères pour
décaisser ses aides le vote d'une oie
comme s'il allait de soi que le
Parlement était à vos ordres je pèse mes
mots monsieur le ministre vous êtes le
seul gouvernement sur les 27 à avoir agi
ainsi
sur le fond vos homologues ont proposé
des critères positifs investir dans
l'hydrogène investir dans le train
public investir pour faire en sorte de
réduire les inégalités sociales et vous
ces critères là étaient motivants le
vôtre relève de la bureaucratie
rétrograde pour notre part nous
préférons la clarté démocratique la
seule qui respecte le peuple aussi
monsieur le ministre vous feriez mieux
de l'assumer clairement assumer que
Bruxelles n'a rien imposé à la France
assumez que soumettent le décaissement
des crédits européens au vote d'une loi
de programmation des finances publiques
découlent du seul engagement du
gouvernement qui désormais ne sait plus
comment faire auprès de Bruxelles parce
que vous êtes pris les pieds dans le
tapis monsieur le ministre
expliquez-nous pourquoi le 27 avril 2021
vous nous disiez je vais vous citer à
nouveau la Commission européenne ne
vient pas nous imposer de l'extérieur de
nouvelles réformes pour bénéficier de
ces 40 milliards d'euros expliquez-nous
désormais pourquoi il veut aujourd'hui
nous faire croire comme il au rapporteur
général dans le courrier que vous lui
avez adressé lundi dernier je cite que
la Commission européenne fait de
l'adoption de la loi de programmation un
prérequis indispensable à sa validation
la deuxième demande de paiement qui
faut-il croire Bruno Le Maire le 27
avril 2021 ou Bruno Le Maire le 25
septembre 2023 maintenant je
souhaiterais m'adresser à nos collègues
à la droite de l'hémicycle qui lors du
premier examen de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques à
l'automne 2022 ont voté contre cette loi
de programmation cette fois-ci vous avez
retourné votre veste mes chers collègues
préférant ne pas faire de vagues vous
vous êtes abstenus entraînant des facto
l'adoption l'adoption de la loi de
programmation en commission dans six
mois j'espère ne pas avoir à entendre
que vous expliquerez à vos électeurs que
Bruxelles nous impose des règles que
nous ne voulons pas alors que la réalité
c'est que c'est vous qui avez cédé au
chantage du gouvernement il est encore
temps ce soir de changer et d'assumer
notre rôle de représentant du peuple
français c'est-à-dire de faire respecter
l'Assemblée nationale et de ne pas céder
au chantage du gouvernement qui encore
une fois s'est mis tout seul dans cette
situation la deuxième motivation qui
justifie cette notion de rejet mes chers
collègues c'est la trajectoire
budgétaire proposée par le gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
en matière de finances publiques vous
devriez vous le savez que les chiffres
ne mentent pas et ils ont une
programmation moi je suis la première à
le reconnaître est un outil intéressant
à la fois sur la trajectoire et à la
fois sur les moyens qu'on se donne pour
y parvenir or dans la copie que vous
nous avez remis
soit vous mentez à Bruxelles en
affichant des marches qui sont trop
hautes soit vous allez casser notre
économie quand on se vend objectif qui
vise à définir les moyens de sa
trajectoire budgétaire le gouvernement
ne dit rien et ça c'est pas moi qui le
dit puisque le Haut Conseil au finance
publique a écrit dans la vie qui nous a
remis je le cite que le respect de la
trajectoire suppose la réalisation d'un
montant important d'économie toujours
peu documenté à ce jour enfin la
troisième et la dernière raison qui
motive cette motion de rejet
découle de la manière dont vous gérez ou
plutôt ne gérez pas les finances
publiques de notre pays depuis 2017 la
dette publique a augmenté de 800
milliards d'euros
800 milliards d'euros et pour la
première fois elle a dépassé le seuil
des 3000 milliards afin juillet 2023
c'est-à-dire il y a un mois le déficit
public dépasse 169 milliards d'euros
quand le montant inscrit dans la loi de
finances pour 2023 pour toute l'année et
de 165 milliards d'euros en 2024 la
France va devoir emprunter 285 milliards
d'euros c'est inédit et sans doute ça
met notre pays en péril
monsieur le ministre messieurs les
ministres en économie le en même temps
ne fonctionne pas parce que les cadeaux
fiscaux que vous avez accordé au plus
aisés finissent toujours par se
transformer en dette à payer par tous
les français et notamment les plus
pauvres
vos paris sur les cadeaux fiscaux n'ont
pas fonctionné la croissance devait
décoller grâce à la suppression de
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune et
la flat taxe elle n'a absolument pas
décollé et vous vous apprêtez
aujourd'hui à faire payer les plus
pauvres pour ne pas avoir à revenir sur
vos cadeaux fiscaux je pense par exemple
au doublement de la franchise médicale
pour l'achat de médicaments remboursé je
pense aux étudiants dont plus un sur
deux de plus de 1 sur 2 déclarent ne pas
manger à sa fin je pense au que toujours
plus nombreuses pour bénéficier des
aides alimentaires c'est pour nous
inacceptable parce que c'est un
dévoiement de notre devise républicaine
liberté égalité fraternité que vous le
vouliez ou non mes chers collègues
l'égalité fait partie de notre pilier de
républicain et cette égalité elle
s’érode petit à petit en tout cas il y a
un indice qui la mesure qui mesure les
inégalités dans notre pays et qui
s'appelle le Ghini et on constate que
depuis 2017 c'est l'Insee qui le dit il
s'est détérioré ce qui signifie que les
inégalités en France ont augmenté pour
l'ensemble de ces trois raisons il y en
aurait d'autres je vous invite mes chers
collègues à voter cette motion de rejet
je vous invite à faire entendre la voix
du Parlement qui ne saurait être méprisé
ni à Bruxelles ni à Paris je vous
remercie
merci madame la Présidente sur le vote
de la motion de rejet préalable je suis
saisi par les groupes de la France
insoumise et le groupe socialiste d'une
demande de scrutin public qui est
annoncée dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale
j'ai des demandes de parole
d'explication de vote par groupe pour me
rassembler en National et pour 2 minutes
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
le Président Monsieur les ministres
monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues nous avons malheureusement
rarement l'occasion de débattre sur le
fond de nos finances publiques l'abus de
49-3 nuit gravement au débat et nous
restons donc sur notre fin depuis
quelques temps et là
convaincu comme à son habitude d'avoir
raison sur tout le gouvernement enchaîne
discours d'autosatisfaction sur discours
d'autosatisfaction sans aucune once de
remise en question nous venons encore
d'en avoir un exemple criant au sens
propre d'ailleurs avec une déconnexion
totale de la réalité cette réalité est
marquée par un appauvrissement de
millions de Français par une dette
abyssale plus 700 millions d'euros
depuis 6 ans par des choix
catastrophiques et coûteux marché
européen électricité abandons temporaire
du nucléaire emprunt d’excès entre
autres et par un record de prélèvement
obligatoire et cette loi qui n'apporte
pas grand chose et sont un peu le
réchauffés auraient au moins tu vas être
l'occasion du débat de fond que nous
appelons tous de nos vœux tous peut-être
pas car au lieu de s'ouvrir au dialogue
le gouvernement campe sur ses positions
parfois de manière assez étonnante en
effet se faire le centre du
désendettement et de la réduction des
dépenses publiques en étant le champion
du déficit et de la dette excusez-moi
mais il fallait oser la surdité
macroniste à toute proposition
tant peu à peu à transformer le Mozart
de la finance plutôt en Beethoven avec
en résultat toujours un recueillen pour
notre économie alors pour remplacer le
dialogue le gouvernement agite le
spectre du non versement de milliards
d'euros du fait d'une nasse européenne
dans laquelle il sait il nous l'avouer
lui-même en Pétré il faut voter nous
assène-t-il mais une majorité ça a été
dit ça se crée dans le dialogue ça ne se
crée pas avec un pistolet européen sur
la tempe le gouvernement parle de
crédibilité mais il n'est pas crédible
lorsqu'il affiche une volonté dialogue
difficile à l'heure de l'être en matière
budgétaire un projet incohérent à des
décisions incohérentes vous rajoutez un
comportement incohérent ceci dans ce
signe engage aujourd'hui pas
confiance ça s'appelle une occasion
ratée mais dans ce gouvernement ce n'est
pas la première et ce ne sera
malheureusement pas la dernière
[Applaudissements]
qui qui intervient au groupe LFI
vous avez la parole
vous intervenez de où vous voulez mais
pour deux minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci messieurs les ministres
nous sommes qu'au troisième jour de la
session parlementaire que déjà le
gouvernement va utiliser le 49-3 alors
on espérait rien de vous mais on est
quand même un peu déçu l'année dernière
vous aviez au moins attendu quelques
semaines avant de faire 10 49-3 sur le
budget alors ça annonce la couleur pour
cette année rien n'a changé vous êtes
toujours aussi minoritaire donc
autoritaire et vous allez une nouvelle
fois utilisez les outils de la 5ème
République pour passer en force la loi
dont nous traitons aujourd'hui est aussi
brutal que vaut 49-3 c'est une loi
d'austérité budgétaire cette loi
plafonne à la baisse les dépenses des
dépenses publiques alors que les besoins
écologiques et sociaux eux augmentent
parce que quand vous mettez des moyens
inférieurs aux besoins alors les besoins
ne sont pas couverts quand vous ouvrez 3
litres réanimation là où il en faut 5
alors des patients vont mourir dans les
couloirs quand vous recrutez deux aesh
alors qu'il en faut 6 alors des enfants
en situation de handicap seront encore
exclues de l'école quand vous fermez une
maternité dans une région où il en
faudrait trois alors vous prenez encore
le risque des femmes à couches dans leur
voiture et vous pouvez pas vous réfugier
derrière la prétendue obligation
européenne pour imposer une austérité le
président Coquerel a démontré qu'il n'en
ne peut pas affirmer que la seule
absence de loi de programmation serait
un motif de blocage de fonds européens
et puis ce 49-3 qui va arriver dans
quelques instants vous permet de
rétablir encore une fois très
discrètement l'article 16 que nous avons
rejeté en commission des finances qui
contraint les dépenses des collectivités
dans leur dépenses de fonctionnement
justement
enfin que dire de la position du
rassemblement national qui va s'abstenir
sur cette loi à quelques mois d'une
campagne européenne où ils vont
prétendre être un rempart contre le
stérilité budgétaire venu de Bruxelles
une fois de plus vous démontrez que vous
êtes une vraie arnaque sociale qui ne
fait pas barrage loi austéritaires ni
dans cette assemblée ni au Parlement
européen la position de mon groupe la
France insoumise à l'éclair l'austérité
c'est non donc nous voterons cette
notion de rejet
[Applaudissements]
alors pour les républicains toujours
pour deux minutes Marie-Christine Dalloz
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur leur rapporteur
général monsieur le Président de la
Commission
nous allons le groupe les républicains
va s'accorder sur la nécessité d'une loi
de programmation des finances publiques
je pense que c'est important qu'on se
donne une trajectoire ça on est d'accord
seulement la trajectoire affichée
est-elle si elle est nécessaire est-elle
suffisante
et une autre question est-ce que le
projet de loi de finances 2024 traduit
concrètement la trajectoire qui est
proposée dans la loi de programmation de
finance publique j'ai une réponse à un
c'est non
le Sénat avait lui largement contribuer
à construire cette trajectoire dans le
cadre de la loi de programmation des
finances publiques c'est dommage lundi
après-midi le gouvernement a déposé très
amendement 84 pages de d'amendement avec
peu de temps pour les étudier et nous
n'avons pas et nous avons vous avez
modifié la trajectoire que le Sénat
avait programmé
pour autant pour autant le groupe les
républicains ne votera pas cette motion
de rejet elle ne votera pas cette motion
de rejet pourquoi parce que la voix du
Parlement je vais apprendre cela à ma
collègue vice-présidente qui a été
longtemps la commission des finances la
voix du Parlement elle peut se faire
entendre autrement que par
systématiquement sur tous les textes une
motion de rejet ça c'est de la position
systématique la voix du Parlement la
voix du Parlement mesdames et messieurs
les députés la voix du Parlement se
sépare amendement séparation c'est dans
le cadre d'un débat jamais avec vos cris
et vos hurlements sur des motion de
rejet pour toutes ces raisons le groupe
les républicains ne votera pas cette
motion de rejet
alors
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues chers collègues est-ce
que chacun peut écouter l'autre c'est
deux minutes par groupe on peut le faire
dans le silence quand même est terminé
chacun exprime sa position monsieur
Laquila pour le groupe démocrate
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le Président de la
Commission sur le rapporteur général
chers collègues hier soir la commission
des finances de l'Assemblée nationale a
montré une vision éclairée en adoptant
le projet de loi de programmation de
finances publiques pour 2023 2027 c'est
un acte louable non seulement pour la
rigueur des débats mais aussi pour le
bien de nos finances publiques
alors c'est très autonome de voir une
nouvelle fois une motion de rejet sur
une sur une loi de programmation des
finances publiques et présentée par une
ancienne rapporteur général du budget
qui pourtant connaît l'importance de ce
texte et à la rappeler c'est peut-être
parce que vous avez peur que nous
puissions respecter la trajectoire que
nous souhaitons nous fixer l'adoption
d'une propre trajectoire de nos finances
publiques est absolument vital pour
notre pays n’en déplaise à certains
irresponsables c'est d'abord une
question de crédibilité à l'égard de nos
partenaires européens nous ne pouvons
pas être le seul pays à ne pas pouvoir
nous doter d'une trajectoire des
finances publiques crédibles c'est plus
encore le cas dans le contexte du
financement du plan de relance européen
qui je vous le rappelle est une grande
avancée dans la construction européenne
je ne saurais croire Madame la
Présidente rabot que les héritiers enfin
je crois de Jacques Delors et de l'Acte
unique européen rejoignent aujourd'hui
les voix les plus heureuses sceptiques
c'est aussi une question de contrôle des
finances publiques par notre Parlement
sans loi de programmation quelle qu'elle
soit ni le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques si nous autres parlementaires
pourront évaluer avec sérieux la
trajectoire de nos finances publiques
nouveau tronc contre votre motion
merci pour le groupe horizon madame
manié
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général du budget mes chers
collègues je crois que le ministre
Thomas Cazenave la parfaitement dit la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques est un texte pour les
parlementaires un réel outil pour notre
rôle de parlementaire aussi j'avoue que
je ne comprends pas bien que des
parlementaires souhaitent tout
simplement s'en priver en tout cas ce
n'est pas le choix du groupe horizon et
c'est pour ça que nous voterons contre
évidemment cette motion de rejet je vous
remercie
merci pour le groupe écologiste madame
SAS
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues posons-le
d'emblée nous voterons cette motion de
rejet parce que la trajectoire
budgétaire que vous proposez ne répond
en rien aux enjeux environnementaux et
sociaux de notre pays elle ne permet pas
le réarmement de nos services publics en
particulier de notre système de santé
elle ne répond pas aux besoins de nos
collectivités puisqu'elle anticipe une
réduction de leurs dépenses de 0,5% par
an en euros courant au moment même où
vous demandez à ces mêmes collectivités
de co-financer les RER métropolitains et
la rénovation thermique des écoles de
France cette trajectoire budgétaire
n'est pas à la hauteur de la
responsabilité qui est celle de notre
génération en matière de transition
écologique vous me parlerez des 7
milliards qui deviennent 10 et qui
deviennent encore 60 mais outre que si
l'on analyse les besoins sectoriels on
en conclut qu'il en faudrait plutôt 14
que 7 j'observe que c'est 7 milliards
ils sont en grande partie consacré aux
surprise à la décarbonation de
l'industrie et à la compétitivité verte
au lieu de protéger d'accompagner les
ménages pour isoler leur logement ou
leur offrir des transports collectifs
accessibles et réguliers nous votre
rendons que cette motion de rejet sur le
fond mais aussi sur la méthode car dans
l'examen de ce texte nous sommes une
fois de plus dans un déni de démocratie
la publication de la trajectoire
budgétaire le matin de l'examen en
commission la reprise du texte du Sénat
qui restreint la possibilité
d'amendement le 49-3 qui se profile on
peut dire que vous ne vous donnez même
plus les apparences d'un exercice
démocratique donc vous l'aurez compris
parce que cette trajectoire budgétaire
est incompatible avec l'ambition
écologique et sociale qui est la nôtre
et parce que le Parlement est une fois
de plus piétiné par un exécutif sourd et
isolé le groupe écologiste votre a cette
notion de rejet
merci pour le groupe GDR monsieur
Tellier
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres collègues l'article 4 de ce
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques et explicite tout sur
les dépenses rien sur les recettes la
baisse du déficit que vous projetez pour
vous conformer aux règles budgétaires
européennes ne sera porté que par un
effort de dépenses pire l'effort en
prélèvement obligatoire sera au mieux
neutre ou pire négatif comme c'est le
cas pour les années 2024 et 2025 pire
vous vous dédouanez sur les
collectivités territoriales en leur
fixant une trajectoire sous le niveau de
l'inflation
ce texte et la parfaite démonstration
que les règles européennes
que les règles européennes les objectifs
de socle budgétaires le socle structurel
ne servent qu'un objectif idéologique
réduire à toujours plus les dépenses
publiques et liquider à moins et à terme
le modèle social français c'est un choix
politique qui est fait nous ne le
partageons pas d'autres voix existent
nous portons celle
qui se donnent plus de justice fiscale
pour financer notre modèle social et les
investissements de demain pour une
transition écologique en conséquence
nous voterons cette motion de rejet
préalable
merci pour le groupe pilote monsieur de
Courson
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues
madame bravo a évoqué trois raisons dans
sa notion de rejet
la première raison est notre groupe la
partage
c'est que vouloir faire voter le
Parlement l'Assemblée nationale en
l'espèce sur un texte qui a été repoussé
avec une très forte majorité il y a un
an c'est quand même assez étrange du
point de vue démocratique
j'ajoute j'ajoute en plus que l'espèce
de chantage au versement des aides
européennes est indécent
car comme Madame bravo la rappeler c'est
le gouvernement actuel qui sent que le
Parlement les autorisé a mis cette
condition
qui d'ailleurs n'est pas si clair que
cela comme la note qui nous a été faite
par la commission des finances le
montrent c'est une possibilité de
bloquer mais c'est pas mécanique c'est
pas automatique comme souvent dans
l'Union européenne ça se résoudra
politiquement et si vous voulez mon
sentiment comme dans d'autres affaires
ça sera effectivement débloqué
donc ce premier argument de Madame bravo
je le partage entièrement avec notre
groupe
alors il y a un deuxième argument qui a
été utilisé c'est la trajectoire
budgétaire c'est vrai que c'est
extrêmement étrange on fait aucune
économie en 2024 et on nous explique que
c'est en 2025 qu'on va faire 12
milliards mais on sait pas ce que c'est
on verra mais enfin c'est pas sérieux
c'est pas sérieux cette trajectoire
budgétaire n'est pas sérieuse et je
passe sur les hypothèses
macroéconomiques complètement irréaliste
je reviendrai s'il y a un débat tout à
l'heure et puis il y a une troisième
raison qui est que puis-je rappeler à la
minorité présidentielle qu'elle est au
pouvoir depuis 6 ans
et est-ce que vous avez redressé les
finances publiques en 6 ans mais vous
les avez plantés vous les avez plantés
merci et je parle hors covid et Orson
pour le groupe Renaissance monsieur
Lefebvre
merci monsieur le président
monsieur de Courson on attend vos
propositions de réduction de dépenses
après que vous ayez contribué à essayer
de faire échouer la réforme des
retraites madame madame la Présidente
rabot
madame la Présidente rabot
2012 cette assemblée à de la mémoire
c'est vous qui avez contribué à
transcrire dans le droit national la loi
de programmation des finances publiques
vous contribuez aujourd'hui à refuser un
débat que vous avez vous-même souhaité
inscrire dans la loi il faut vous en
expliquer madame rabot le Parti
socialiste fut un temps était un grand
parti européen à parti qui avait la
construction européenne cheville au
corps votez cette notion de rejet
préalable c'est affaiblir la position de
la France dans l'Union européenne
j'entendais notre collègue sensu nous
dire il faut revoir les règles
européennes les règles budgétaires
européennes mais avec quel crédibilité
la France va-t-elle aller négocier les
règles européennes quand elle sera le
seul pays à ne pas avoir de loi de
programmation madame rabot répondez à
cette question
madame bravo votez cette notion de rejet
c'est voter contre nous-mêmes et vous le
savez vous le savez pertinemment parce
que cette loi de programmation ce sont
des outils pour contrôler l'action du
gouvernement et d'ailleurs on en arrive
à ce paradoxe que monsieur Brun lui-même
a fait adopter un amendement un
amendement utile et il souhaite
aujourd'hui refuser cette amendement au
seul motif que vous voulez vous opposer
tout cela n'a absolument aucun sens vous
voulez évaluer l'action du parc du
gouvernement voter ce texte vous voulez
limiter les dépenses fiscales et
sociales votez ce texte vous voulez
évaluer la qualité de l'action publique
voter ce texte mais vous ce que vous
faites c'est que vous rejetez le débat
pas un dernier argument sur le fond de
notre politique économique madame bravo
cette notion de rejet préalable dans le
fond c'est vouloir poursuivre une
politique qui n'a pas fonctionné pendant
30 ans et qui a consisté à s'endetter
plus pour taxer plus ça n'a mené qu'à
deux choses le chômage de masse et un
endettement supérieur à tous les autres
pays de la zone euro à cause de vous à
cause de vous en 2017 on paiera plus au
fond de pension que pour investir en
faveur de nos enfants on vous le doit
bien je mets la motion de rejet au vote
la notion de rejet préalable au vote
pour rejoignez vos bancs le scrutin est
ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votant 296 exprimés 294 majorité 148% 19
contre 175 l'assemblée n'a pas adopté
et je donne la parole à Monsieur le
Maire ministre de l'Économie des
Finances de la souveraineté industrielle
et numérique
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
d'abord remercier tous les
parlementaires qui ont rejeté cette
motion au préalable et je voudrais
répondre très simplement pour
l'utilité du débat à Madame rabot dont
l'argumentaire c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire n'a pas convaincu cette
assemblée visiblement et la convaincu ni
Thomas Cazenave ni moi-même
d'abord
vous accusez madame rabot les résultats
économiques du gouvernement et vous
accablez la politique économique du
gouvernement et bien moi je vais vous
dire le fondement sentiment je trouve
vraiment dommage qu'une parlementaire
qu'une vie présidente de la Chambre
nationale qu'un ancien rapportant
général du budget ne soit pas capable de
reconnaître et succès économiques des
entreprises Françaises et des Français
et des salariés français et je vais vous
dire le fond de mon sentiment je trouve
vraiment désolant de devoir aller en
Allemagne à Berlin à Londres en
Grande-Bretagne ou à Madrid en Espagne
pour que ce soit reconnu les effets
positifs de la politique économique
d'Emmanuel Macron
je trouve cela désolant
et je le dis pas pour nous je le dis
même pas pour la majorité mais je le dis
pour les salariés qui travaillent pour
les ouvriers qui font tourner les usines
pour les entrepreneurs qui investissent
pour les jeunes qui prennent des risques
pour les entrepreneurs indépendants qui
sont engagés dans leur travail pour les
agriculteurs pour les patrons
d'exploitation pour tous ceux qui font
réussir la France on devrait leur dire
tous ici collectivement merci merci pour
les 2 millions d'emplois qui ont été
créés merci pour le 1% de croissance
merci pour l'attractivité retrouver de
la France qui accueille aujourd'hui plus
d'investissements sur son territoire que
tous les autres pays européens je trouve
désolant que vous ne soyez pas capable
de reconnaître honnêtement et
sincèrement ces résultats de notre
politique économique
vous dites
vous dites que ce jalon ce jalons de la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques est négatif je rappelle madame
rabot vous le savez parce que vous
connaissez par cœur les textes que nous
avons dépenses déposées 181 jalons à la
Commission européenne vous avez décidé
j'y reviendrai d'extraire celui-ci c'est
l'objet de notre débat ce soir c'est
bien naturel mais vous auriez pu citer
aussi par ODT intellectuelle tous les
autres jalons positifs qui figurent dans
ce texte nous avons adressé à la
Commission européenne notre engagement à
rénover les logements sociaux notre
engagement a des carboné d'industrie
notre engagement à mettre en place un
crédit d'impôt pour l'industrie verte
notre engagement à développer
l'hydrogène carbonée notre engagement à
voir nos propres usines de batterie
électrique tous ces jalons positifs vous
auriez pu par souci d'honnêteté les
cités et ce jalon de la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
est-il si inutile non il est nécessaire
il est d'abord nécessaire pas pour la
commission pas simplement pour les
versements mais il est nécessaire pour
nous il est nécessaire pour la France
quand on a une dette aussi élevée que
nous traînons depuis 30 ans quand nous
avons des taux d'intérêts qui sont
remontés après de 4%, il est nécessaire
d'avoir une trajectoire des finances
publiques pour désendetter le pays
revenir sous les trois pour cent et
arrêter les dépenses inutiles dans la
charge de la dette il est nécessaire
aussi parce que dans son courrier des
six et 21 septembre 2023 il est indiqué
très clairement que l'adoption de la loi
de finances la loi de programmation des
finances publiques est indispensable aux
décaissement de la deuxième demande de
paiement et puis il y a une toute
dernière raison qui fait que nous ne
pouvons pas nous passer de loin de
programmation des finances publiques
vous qui êtes une Européenne convaincue
les 18 autres États membres de la zone
euro ont déjà une trajectoire plurie
annuelle des finances publiques et je
n'ai aucune envie que la France reste le
petit mouton noir sur le bord du chemin
qui toute seule résistante à l'ensemble
de ses partenaires européens n'auraient
pas de loi de programmation des finances
publiques
et si jamais vous n'êtes pas convaincu
madame rabot
[Applaudissements]
qui madame rabot vous n'êtes pas
convaincu je vous rappelle que tous vos
partenaires socialistes en Europe sans
exception ont été capables de ramener
leur pays sous 3% de déficit public et
que tout sans exception le feront avant
nous je rappelle que le Portugal
socialiste a un âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 67 ans et a déjà des comptes
publics à l'équilibre je rappelle que
l'Espagne de Monsieur Sanchez reviendra
sur 3% de déficit public en 2025 que
l'Allemagne de Monsieur Scholtz
socialiste reviendra sous les 3% de
déficits publics en 2024 et bien
pourquoi ce que des socialistes
européens ne sont pas capables vous
madame rabot vous ne seriez pas capable
de le faire aussi voter donc notre loi
de programmation des finances publiques
vous serez cohérente par rapport aux
autres gouvernements socialistes
européens
et bien j'ouvre la discussion générale
pour 5 minutes par orateur le premier
d'entre eux pour le groupe du
Rassemblement national Monsieur Philippe
lotiau
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur général
mes chers collègues
Théophile Gautier disait
il n'y a de vraiment beau que ce qui ne
peut servir à rien
et cette phrase qu'on fait à votre
projet de loi anesthétisme inattendu
en effet à quoi nous sert cette loi non
contraignante que vous nous présentez de
nouveau comme un enfant puni le plat de
la veille sa justification principale
est que son adoption conditionnerait le
versement à la France des fonds
européens ont-ils du plan de relance
soit 19 voire 27 milliards d'euros qui
dit mieux vous en avez donc appelé à la
concertation et au dialogue avec les
oppositions dont acte on ne peut certes
que déplorer cette forme de chantage
européen dans lequel vous êtes vous-même
engagé et qui lustre notre perte
constante de souveraineté pour autant
l'intérêt national qui nous guide peut
parfois conduire à dépasser certaines
oppositions au moment d'un vote
mais de dépassement en commission
commence début de séance il n'y en a pas
eu de votre part
les débats ont illustré que vous
persistez à faire de ce texte technique
qui devrait être amendée pour le rendre
à tant soit peu acceptable un programme
politique intouchable de même que vous
n'avez pas répondu de manière vraiment
argumentée aux questions posées par vos
oppositions sur le caractère impératif
de la notion cette loi vous ne les avez
pas non plus écoutés alors rêvons cette
nocturne que de cette discussion
jaillisse la lumière car à ce stade
l'essentiel du test consiste notamment
le document annexe en un nouvel exercice
d'auto satisfaction dont vous avez le
secret à vous lire on pourrait croire
que le monde entier nous envie notre
situation budgétaire notre déficit notre
dette le poids de notre prélèvement
obligatoire notre pouvoir d'achat en
berne et notre commerce extérieur à la
dérive
il faut par ailleurs rappeler que les
lois de programmation je cite le Conseil
des finances publiques repose sur des
hypothèses généralement optimistes et
rapidement obsolètes leurs objectifs
n'ont que rarement été atteints depuis
2008 la situation des finances publiques
c'est ainsi nettement démerdes
détériorées contrairement aux objectifs
affichés avec constance par les lois de
programmation que les hypothèses soient
optimistes nous l'avions déjà constaté
l'an dernier et à l'instar de la
quasi-totalité des institutions
spécialisées le constatant encore sans
compter votre pari d'une contribution du
commerce extérieur à la croissance qui
laisse songeur comme celui d'une baisse
du taux d'épargne des ménages dans un
contexte d'incertitude ce à leur même
que vous ne tenez pas compte de l'impact
à venir d'une crise du logement et
partant du secteur du BTP car il va
grande vitesse et voulait être sans
véritable réaction que les hypothèses
soient rapidement obsolètes les nombreux
changements que vous introduisez par
rapport au chiffre fournis il y a
quelques mois suffisent à nous en
convaincre validant la sentence de
Pierre Dac pour qui les prévisions sont
difficiles surtout quand elles
concernent l'avenir et pourtant malgré
cela votre trajectoire des finances
publiques demeure peu ambitieuse la
plupart des économies attendues sont nos
documents t renvoyaient à futur revue de
dépenses alors même qu'il existe des
économies évidentes de la réduction des
coûts de l'immigration de l'audiovisuel
public à la lutte contre les fraudes ou
la suram administration notamment notre
système de santé nous aurons l'occasion
d'y revenir lors de l'examen du PLF du
PLFSS et on voit même que les
prélèvements obligatoires dont nous
sommes les champions incontestés
devraient repartir d'ici peu à la hausse
de 44% 2023 à 44,4% 2025 pour
paraphraser Clemenceau la France est un
pays extraordinaire vous y plantez du
Macron il épouse des prélèvements
obligatoires
ce qui risque
ceux qui risquent revanche de ne plus
pousser ce sont les fruits et légumes
dans nos campagnes avec un nouveau coup
de poignard pour nos agriculteurs comme
d'ailleurs pour nos pécheurs et le
secteur du BTP du fait de la fin
programmer l'exonération du GNR des
secteurs en crise qui n'avaient vraiment
pas besoin de cela en ce moment pour une
économie restreinte au regard de
l'impact de cette mesure votre
trajectoire tient également compte nous
a-t-on annoncé d'un nouveau chèque pour
certains actifs pour faire mine de
compenser la hausse du coût du carburant
une nouvelle usine à gaz sans grand
impact contrairement à celle Corée la
baisse de la TVA que nous vous demandons
depuis des mois vous y restez sourd vous
y restez sourds mais sachez que votre
politique d'échec ne serait masquée
l'échec de votre politique
il est temps dans le secteur de
l'énergie vos atermoiements face au
marché européen l'électricité
contribuent à meurtrer chaque jour des
millions de Français nous pouvons aussi
déplorer que ce texte vis encore à
contraindre des collectivités locales
alors même qu'elles ne sont responsables
ni des déficits ni de la dérive de la
dette nous aurons donc plusieurs
amendements de nouveau notamment sur la
suppression de Chi déjà obsolète le
soutien de collectivités une réflexion
sur les eati ou encore une véritable
concertation sur la révision des
dépenses structurelles de l'État et de
ses opérateurs nous tirons alors les
conditions définitives pour notre des
conclusions définitives pour notre vote
et je conclus de votre capacité réelle
de dialogue même si nous nourrissons
guère d'illusions à ce propos je vous
remercie
5 minutes pour le groupe la France
insoumise pour Monsieur Guiraud
[Applaudissements]
bien monsieur le président
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
monsieur le ministre
cazena vous commencez très mal votre
nouvelle responsabilité
je vous le dis parce que j'espère que
quand ce débat sera terminé vous irez
regarder les vidéos notamment celle de
votre intervention et peut-être que vous
rendrez compte que dire
à propos de la loi je vous cite qu'elle
est construite avec le Parlement avec un
grand sourire moqueur
alors que dans même pas une heure la
première ministre va probablement
débarquer pour nous empêcher à 49-3 qui
va nous empêcher de voter
c'est une attitude qui dégoûte les
Français et qui manquent cruellement de
dignité et de hauteur
vous les macronistes qui a toujours là
nous donner des belles leçons de
maintien vous avez peut-être des grandes
cravates mais je vous assure que des
fois vous faites vraiment de la toute
petite politique
[Applaudissements]
et toute cette comédie pourquoi
pour obéir servilement à une commission
européenne qui nous ordonne absolument
de saigner nos écoles nos hôpitaux nos
mairies nos départements notre sécurité
sociale car sinon paraît-il paraît-il
parce qu'on en a jamais eu la preuve
formelle on nous versera pas 18
milliards d'euros et même si c'était
vrai nous la France on accepterait ça
contributeur net au budget de l'Union
européenne vous vous acceptez nous la
France insoumise nous refusons
en plus franchement
[Musique]
cette fois on aurait pu aller au vote
on aurait pu aller au vote parce que
cette fois vous aviez un allié
il y en a qu'on commençait à avoir la
tremblote on rassemblement national pour
ne surtout pas déplaire à la Commission
européenne
vous vous êtes très fort 15 ans a joué
les patriotes la première fois que
Bruxelles vous souffle dessus votre
femme c'est un
[Applaudissements]
un texte que vous dites indispensable
monsieur le ministre de l'économie à la
crédibilité budgétaire vous dites ça
j'aimerais savoir
quelle est la dernière fois qu'on a
respecté une loi de programmation des
finances publiques monsieur le ministre
jamais jamais alors que votre copie est
encore encrassée d'erreur je viens de
recevoir une alerte à FP sur mon
téléphone
elle dit budget 2024 le Conseil des
finances publiques juge élevé la
prévision de croissance et optimiste
celle du déficit
votre copie est truffé d'erreur vous ne
nous écoutez pas ça fait un an que
monsieur le ministre Bruno Le Maire est
en train de gravir le pic de l'inflation
et je vous assure qu'il est en train de
manquer d'oxygène quand il s'agit de
faire les prévisions macroéconomiques du
pays
avec des bobards les effets positifs sur
l'économie parce que l'impôt sur les
sociétés sentent il y a quand même
quelque chose qui vous échappe
sur les rentrées fiscales de l'impôt sur
les sociétés
mais jamais quasiment dans l'histoire de
notre pays les marges des entreprises
ont été aussi fortes avec l'inflation
donc évidemment il y a énormément
d'argent qui est rentré et mécaniquement
les rentrées d'argent avec les impôts
sont été augmentés CAC 40 1700 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires 19% en
plus sur un an énergie 23 milliards
d'euros de bénéfices 14 % de plus sur un
an mais peut-être qu'au lieu de se
satisfaire de n'avoir rien fait on
aurait pu remettre le taux d'impôt sur
les sociétés sur ces entreprises à 33%
je vous assure que là la France aurait
eu de l'argent pour financer ses
services publics
[Applaudissements]
quant aux collectivités locales que nous
avons ensemble en commission nous avons
battu l'article 16 vous êtes en train de
nous expliquer qu'il va falloir qu'elle
baisse leurs dépenses de fonctionnement
mais si on baisse les dépenses de
fonctionnement mais comment on va
chauffer les écoles cet hiver
comment on va payer les minima sociaux
avec les départements qui va aider les
personnes en situation de handicap
vous êtes en train de mettre à genoux
avec cette loi les collectivités
territoriales qui sont aussi faut-il le
rappeler le premier investisseur public
du pays voilà ce que vous allez mettre à
genoux
[Applaudissements]
il y aurait
tant de choses plus intéressantes à
faire à commencer par se dire que
j'entends souvent parler des
prélèvements obligatoires qui sont en
baisse c'est faux pour les classes
populaires les prélèvements obligatoires
ne sont pas en baisse parce que les
réductions d'impôts que vous avez prévu
elle concerne pas les classes populaires
par contre quand ils vont au supermarché
par contre quand ils vont à la station
essence là je peux vous dire qu'ils
sentent le poids de la TVA et de ce
genre de taxe
et qu'au lieu d'en affecter 100
milliards pour compenser les
exonérations de cotisations sociales le
premier geste que vous auriez pu avoir
en faveur de la consommation populaire
c'est de leur rendre d'augmenter les
salaires d'augmenter les minima sociaux
pour que les gens vivent dignement voilà
exactement pourquoi nous nous opposerons
à votre code programmation des finances
publiques
alors pour le groupe les républicains 5
minutes pour Madame Véronique louvagi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui s'exprime merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres monsieur le président de
la commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général du budget mes chers
collègues nous nous retrouvons pour la
nouvelle lecture du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
2023 2027 au regard de l'état très
inquiétant pour ne pas dire alarmant de
nos comptes publics nous ne pouvons que
nous étonner que le gouvernement ait
attendu quasiment un an après l'échec de
la CMP le 15 novembre dernier pour
examiner deux nouveaux ce texte suite au
rejet le 25 octobre par l'Assemblée
nationale de ce texte Roger auquel les
députés les républicains ont contribué
le Sénat a adopté un projet de loi très
différent en rendant ce texte finalement
très proche de ce que nous souhaitions
avec notamment un effort supplémentaire
demandé à l'État en matière de réduction
de ses dépenses de fonctionnement avec
la suppression du pacte de confiance
entre l'État et les collectivités
territoriales et une incitation du
gouvernement à réduire les effectifs de
la fonction publique d'état
or vous ne voulez pas retenir cette
version vertueuse du Sénat en effet
lundi dernier vous nous avez présenté
des amendements dont nous ne pouvons que
déplorer le dépôt tardif quelques heures
avant l'examen sur un texte par ailleurs
traité technique c'est la raison pour
laquelle en commission des finances
lundi soir après avoir voté contre tous
les amendements du Gouvernement qui
réécrivent complètement cette loi de
programmation des finances publiques les
députés les républicains n'ont pas
participé au vote comme en première
lecture hélas ce texte traduit un manque
d'ambition coupable et un renoncement au
redressement de nos comptes alors que ce
texte aurait pu avoir un impact
déterminant et traduire une réelle
volonté politique pour en finir avec le
désolant triptyque français des 3D dette
déficit et dépenses parlons en premier
lieu de la dette qui dépasse aujourd'hui
3000 milliards d'euros et qui a un tas
de rat atteindra en 2027 108,1 point de
PIB avec une charge qui pourrait être de
4 milliards d'euros selon le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques et dont
vous portez la responsabilité
rendez-vous compte les intérêts vont
être le premier budget de l'État
dépassant largement le budget de
l'Éducation nationale et représentant
trois fois le budget de l'intérieur on
regarde de cette explosion de la dette
vous auriez dû engager le pays dans une
ambition vertueuse de diminution de la
dépense publique parlons du déficit
maintenant la France sera le dernier
pays d'Europe le dernier pays d'Europe à
revenir sous la barre des 3% de déficit
en 2027 alors que tous les autres pays
européens y parviendront en 2025 au plus
tard et ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est Pierre Moscovici président du Haut
Conseil des finances publiques qui le
souligne et je le cite la trajectoire
est un peu améliorée par rapport au
projet de loi initiale mais le passage
sous les 3% apparaît tardif l'Irlande la
Grèce l'Allemagne le Portugal les
Pays-Bas sont déjà sous les trois pour
cent vise 2024 l'Italie 2025 et la
Belgique 2026 et nous et nous nous
attendons 2027 pour revenir sous la
barre des 3% de déficit maintenant
venons-en aux dépenses la situation vous
ne l'ignorez pas est extrêmement
critique puisque la France est le taux
de dépenses publiques le plus élevé
d'Europe alors certes vous nous proposez
dans l'orientation de la trajectoire une
diminution de la dépense publique de
l'État de 0,9 points en moyenne en
volume par an alors c'est vrai c'est une
attention louable mais ces économies
pérennes qui apparaissent pour 12
milliards d'euros qui pourraient en
résulter dès 2025 c'est-à-dire demain
serait réparti entre l'État et la sphère
sociale mais ne sont aucunement
documentés la version que vous nous
proposez est extrêmement décevante
sachant par ailleurs que l'estimation de
l'écart de production et celle de la
croissance potentielle qui constitue le
fondement essentiel de la construction
de cette loi de programmation des
finances publiques apparaissent
optimiste selon le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques mais même avec ces
scénarios optimistes voire sur des
hypothèses probablement irréalistes les
objectifs à l'horizon de 2027 sont
extrêmement décevants et que dire
également de la situation des
prélèvements obligatoires avec un record
historique en 2022 nous restons les
champions en Europe et dans le monde
avec le Danemark en matière de
prélèvement obligatoire vous nous
proposez tout simplement une stagnation
de ces prélèvements et aucune des
munitions ce que nous appelons pourtant
de nos vœux car oui pour redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux Français il faut
baisser les cotisations les taxes et les
différentes impositions ce que vous ne
faites aucunement et là cette version
complètement réécrite par rapport à la
version du Sénat est une énième occasion
manquée et se révèle extrêmement
décevante tant elle nous confirme que le
gouvernement n'a toujours pas pris
conscience de l'impérius nécessité pour
la France de se désentetter pour toutes
ces raisons la majorité des députés les
républicains refusent de vous suivre sur
ce projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques je vous remercie
merci pour le groupe démocrate Monsieur
Pascal Lecan
comment on fait monter
sur le président
monsieur les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur rapporteur général chers
collègues
nous nous retrouvons donc aujourd'hui
pour discuter de nouvelles fois de la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques car d'adoption d'une
trajectoire ambitieuse et responsable
de nos finances publiques n'est pas une
option mais tout simplement une
nécessité pour notre pays comme la
rappeler tout à l'heure le rapporteur
général il est essentiel que la France
démonte sa capacité à se donner un cap
une trajectoire et un véritable cadre
vers le redressement de ses finances
publiques il y a là un triple en jeu la
crédibilité la souveraineté
et la protection de notre économie je
commencerai par le sujet de la
crédibilité comment imaginer en effet
que nous serions le seul pays de la zone
euro qui ne se doterait pas d'une loi de
programmation des finances publiques
au-delà d'images politiques désastreuses
qui serait renvoyée à nos partenaires
cela nous décrivaliserait tout autant
auprès de l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques
cette loi que certains d'entre vous
juste avant semble juger inutile sert de
garantir aux investisseurs quant à la
stabilité financière de notre pays et je
tiens à rappeler ici que les agences de
notation nous disent et Fitch rendront
leur décision à la fin du mois d'octobre
sur la prestation du risque France
nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre de
voir notre dégradé avec pour conséquence
mécanique
l'augmentation de la charge de la dette
et de doutes et des taux d'intérêt que
l'État les collectivités territoriales
les entreprises et les ménages auront à
payer cela ralentirait les flux vers la
France remettant en cause six années de
travail qui ont fait de notre pays la
première destination des investissements
étrangers en Europe ces investissements
ont aussi maintenus ou créés plus de 58
000 emplois en 2022 en France
en s'attaquant à eux on s'attaque bien
sûr à l'emploi alors que depuis six ans
jour après jour semaine après semaine
moi après moi trimestre après trimestre
elle travaille immense a été réalisé
collectivement pour réduire le taux de
chômage à 7%, tôt le plus bas enregistré
depuis 15 ans certainement l'expression
la plus concrète pour les Françaises et
les Français de la réussite économique
de la France et en tout cas c'est ainsi
que le regard d'aujourd'hui nos voisins
européens
ce texte revêt aussi un très fort en jeu
de souveraineté le versement des
prochains paiements du plan national de
relance et de résilience par la
Commission européenne et conditionnée à
son adoption on parle ici de 18
milliards d'euros pour 2023 et 2024 une
somme énorme c'est ni plus ni moins que
le budget sécurité du ministère de
l'Intérieur nous pouvons tout simplement
pas nous priver d'une selle somme qui
nous revient de droit c'est autant que
nous devrions potentiellement retirer à
nos politiques sociales de transition
écologique ou de soutien au pouvoir
d'achat
enfin cette loi de programmation des
finances publiques doit nous permettre
de protéger et de garantir la réussite
de notre économie dans les années à
venir en lui fixant avec cape clair de
désencatement et de maîtrise de nos
dépenses publiques en toute
responsabilité
avec ce texte vous l'avez dit messieurs
les ministres nous allons ramener la
France à un déficit public de
2,7%, un taux de prélèvement obligatoire
de 44,4%
et à tout à une dette publique de 108,1%
du PIB en 2027
ratio tous dans la direction des
propositions de nos collègues sénateurs
et des députés républicains
ce que nous dessinons avec cette loi
c'est aussi après plusieurs années
d'incertitude liées au covid à la guerre
en Ukraine le post-urgence le pérenne il
nous faut absolument sortir du logiciel
de gestion de crise pour retrouver la
stabilité et investir dans l'avenir
notre rôle est d'éclaircir l'horizon
économique de le rendre plus lisible
pour protéger le pouvoir d'achat pour
donner un environnement sécurisé aux
entreprises aux françaises et aux
Français dans lequel ils peuvent
s'engager dans leur projet
d'investissement dans leur projet de vie
je voudrais enfin citer ici notre
nouveau ministre des comptes publics
hier c'était le PFP n'est pas un texte
budgétaire elle est tout simplement un
texte de méthode pour les finances
publiques
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe
démocrate votera en cohérence et en
responsabilité ce projet de loi et
espère que les Forces Républicaines
attachées
à la résilience et à la réussite de
notre économie feront de même je vous
remercie
merci pour le groupe socialiste 5
minutes avec la présidente
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
mes chers collègues alors je voulais
utiliser cette discussion générale pour
répondre à monsieur le ministre Bruno Le
Maire mais j'imagine qu'on pourrait lui
transmettre mes propos pour être bien
clair oui je suis favorable à une loi de
programmation des finances publiques oui
je pense qu'il est utile d'avoir une
projection de savoir ce qu'on veut faire
dans les cinq prochaines années à venir
et oui je pense qu'il est important de
définir une méthode pour y parvenir mais
non je ne suis pas favorable à la vôtre
c'est la vôtre qui pose problème c'est
la vôtre que le Haut Conseil au finance
publique a remises en cause et c'est la
vôtre qui n'est pas crédible elle n'est
pas crédible sur la trajectoire et elle
encore moins crédible sur la méthode
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle n'est pas
crédible sur la trajectoire puisque vous
proposez des réductions de déficit
public qui n'ont jamais été atteintes
sauf à casser notre économie donc c'est
une réponse une question très claire que
je vous pose est-ce que pour envisager
les sauts les réductions déficit public
que vous avez inscrit dans cette loi de
programmation des finances publiques
vous assumez de casser notre économie
sinon vous nous dites clairement comment
vous faites oui je voudrais toujours
répondre aux observations du ministre de
l'Économie des Finances oui je suis
admirative reconnaissante pour tous les
travailleurs les chercheurs les ouvriers
les agriculteurs les professeurs les
infirmiers les médecins toutes les
professions de notre pays qui créent de
la valeur pour notre pays alors je
n'admets pas que monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances émettent un
doute là-dessus et justement parce que
je suis en admiration et reconnaissante
pour leur travail pour leur énergie pour
leur engagement je pense et je ne peux
pas me satisfaire que la France n'arrive
pas à décoller au-delà de 1% de
croissance par an la croissance il y a
un il y a une révolution qui se qui est
devant nous avec la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est une
opportunité
identique à celle de la révolution
industrielle et quand il y a une
révolution industrielle il y a eu des
investissements massifs il y a eu de des
projets qui ont été lancés l'État n'est
pas resté absent aujourd'hui l'État ne
remplit pas son rôle et parce qu'ils ne
le remplit pas c'est chercheur ces
ouvriers c'est travailleurs qui ont
véritablement qui produisent qui crée de
la valeur pour notre pays pourrez-vous
leur action démultiplier avec un soutien
de l'État qui passe par de
l'investissement qui passe par de la
planification écologique qui passe par
un minimum d'organisation qui fasse que
vous ne vouliez pas que ce qui fasse que
vous ne faites pas c'est à dire quand on
fait de la rénovation thermique et bien
on commence par les immeubles ça a
beaucoup plus d'efficacité et ça il n'y
a rien du tout dans les plans que vous
proposez aujourd'hui oui
ça sera le troisième oui au ministre de
l'Économie des Finances oui je crois à
l'Europe oui oui je crois l'Europe oui
je crois à l'Europe mais vous savez vous
savez j'étais encore à Berlin lundi
dernier quand j'explique à nos collègues
également que en France on ne vote plus
le budget il se demande très
sérieusement ce qui arrive à la patrie
des droits de l'homme et à la au pays
qui a été en capacité d'initier une
grande démocratie oui il se pose la
question oui se pose la question il se
pose une question sur votre
fonctionnement il se pose des questions
il se pose des questions sur la manière
dont la démocratie fonctionne en France
il se pose des questions sur les 800
milliards je pèse bien mes mots 800
milliards de dettes supplémentaires que
vous avez engrangé depuis 2017 sans la
rendre solution
il se pose toutes ces questions là et
oui les nos partenaires européens nous
regardent avec grande inquiétude c'est
pas votre loi de programmation qui va
permettre de répondre à la moindre de
leurs inquiétudes alors la vraie
question qui se pose sur une loi de
programmation des finances publiques
c'est comment on arrive à créer de la
valeur encore plus dans le pays pour que
nous puissions assurer nos équilibres
sociaux nous puissions faire en sorte
que notre pays se positionne et redevait
une pleinement souverain 1,3 croissance
potentielle c'est pas à la hauteur c'est
clairement pas à la hauteur aujourd'hui
la manière dont on fabrique de la valeur
dans notre pays c'est 60% de la
consommation 20% de l'investissement et
20% du commerce extérieur quand vous
affaiblissez la consommation dans le
pays vous affaiblissez la croissance
économique et vous créez des désastres
sociaux quand vous affaiblissez
l'investissement dans notre pays qui
n'est pas assez soutenu notamment sur la
transition écologique sur le défi
climatique qui est devant nous vous a
faiblissez notre croissance comme le
commerce extérieur qui est aujourd'hui
dans un déficit abyssal on voit bien que
c'est lui qui freine aussi notre
croissance économique il y a trois
leviers consommation investissement et
commerce extérieur aujourd'hui vous ne
répondez à aucun aucun de ces trois
leviers dans votre loi de programmation
des finances publiques c'est pour ça que
s'il y a un vote nous voterons contre
merci madame la Présidente pour le
groupe horizon 5 minutes avec Madame
manier
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général du budget mes chers
collègues si le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
n'est pas un texte budgétaire à
proprement parler son examen en nouvelle
lecture ce soir nous donne l'occasion de
lancer notre automne budgétaire avec une
vision d'ensemble et sur le long terme
de nos finances publiques je me réjouis
de l'adoption de ce projet de loi en
commission des finances lundi soir car
le rejet du texte l'année dernière dans
cette hémicycle à l'occasion de la
première lecture avait envoyé un fort
mauvais signal car oui une loi de
programmation de nos finances publiques
nous est indispensables nous ne pouvons
nous permettre de naviguer sans boussole
et sans carte alors que la tempête
menace
un retour sous les 3% de déficit public
à l'horizon 2027 doit être notre seul
cap et c'est la condition sinequanone
pour nous permettre collectivement de
pouvoir déployer des ressources
budgétaires significatives si une
nouvelle crise se présentait j'entends
que certains aimeraient un
rétablissement plus rapide plus massif
et quelque part nous souhaiterions
pouvoir aller plus vite mais nous sommes
réalistes et refusons de tomber dans
l'incantation le Yaka faucon n'a jamais
produit d'effet il s'agit donc de se
fixer des objectifs ambitieux mais
atteignables et de nous y tenir ce sera
déjà une belle victoire et puis
j'entends les autres qui voit en cette
loi de programmation le retour de
l'austérité et je leur dis qu'avec une
dépense publique équivalente à
53,8% du PIB en 2027 il devrait revoir
la définition du mot austérité
d'une noix de programmation de nos
finances publiques et donc indispensable
pour être honnête envers les Français et
cette loi elle est aussi indispensable
pour notre honnêteté vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires européens et financiers si
nous ne tenons pas nos engagements alors
nous prendrons le risque de ne pas
pouvoir bénéficier des versements
européens au titre des différents plans
de l'Union européenne ce sont plusieurs
dizaines de milliards d'euros qui
doivent revenir à la France nous parlons
donc là de notre capacité à financer nos
priorités transition écologique en tête
et nos services publics essentiels ce
serait donc prendre un risque qui
pourrait coûter cher très cher et
clairement nous ne souhaitons pas le
prendre enfin et j'en terminerai là une
loi de programmation des finances
publiques est indispensable pour nous
par le menteur dans le cadre de notre
pouvoir de contrôle et d'évaluation elle
fournit des outils comparatifs
indispensables au suivi de la politique
économique et à la gestion des finances
publiques ne nous en privons donc pas
vous l'aurez compris mes chers collègues
le groupe horizon et apparenté votre a
en faveur de ce projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 à 2027 par
responsabilité et par honnêteté je vous
remercie
merci
pour le groupe écologiste 5 minutes pour
Madame SAS
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général chers collègues
monsieur le ministre vous accusez
régulièrement les écologistes d'être
irréalistes ou irresponsable dans leur
propositions mais je veux ici vous
retourner la question
n'est-ce pas irresponsable de votre part
de prévoir une augmentation des crédits
de l'écologie de seulement 2,4 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2026 au moment où le
secrétaire général de l'ONU Antonio
guterese nous alerte sur le début de
l'effondrement climatique n'est-ce pas
irresponsable en particulier de ne
prévoir aucune marge de manœuvre pour le
ferroviaire alors que les experts de la
RT sont catégoriques si nous ne suivons
pas le scénario du coi de planification
écologique pour la régénération et la
modernisation de notre réseau dès 2024
alors nous allons vers une grave
détérioration de notre infrastructure
ferroviaire et une forte baisse du
trafic reléguant une pas encore nos
objectifs en matière de report modal au
rang de chimère n'est-ce pas
irresponsable de votre part de ne
prévoir qu'une augmentation minime des
crédits de la rénovation thermique alors
que le rapport Gontard ça son Estrosi
recommande une augmentation de 1,6
milliards d'euros supplémentaires dès
2024 pour ma prime rénov et 1,5
milliards d'euros pour les logements
sociaux et je ne parle pas de nos écoles
pour lequel il est nécessaire que l'État
à loupe de 3 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires par an pour rénover les
plus de 40 000 écoles vétustes et
énergivores les 500 millions d'euros du
fond vert annoncés pour 2024 sont loin
de répondre à cette exigence n'est-ce
pas irresponsable et j'ajoute totalement
incohérent de prévoir une réduction des
dépenses des collectivités locales de
0,5% par an en euros courant alors même
que vous ne cessez de dire qu'elles
devront cofinancer les RER
métropolitains la rénovation des écoles
et que de fait ce sont les premiers
acteurs de l'adaptation
et que dire de la situation des CCAS
dont la situation financière est dans de
nombreuses communes préoccupantes alors
même que ceux-ci sont en première ligne
pour soutenir les plus vulnérables
d'entre nous des personnes âgées et des
publics précaires n'est-ce pas
irresponsable enfin de prévoir un nom
d'âme hospitalier de 3,2% 2024 et entre
2,6 et 2,8% les années suivantes
nettement inférieur à la croissance
temps decielle des dépenses de santé
alors qu'on connaît les difficultés
structurelles de l'hôpital alors vous
allez me dire on ne peut pas creuser le
déficit budgétaire on risquerait de voir
les charges d'intérêt exploser et obéir
les marges manœuvre pour nos politiques
publiques mais ce n'est pas ce que nous
proposons en responsabilité les
écologistes vous ont proposé un plan de
financement de la transition écologique
documentée progressifs et réaliste assis
sur trois piliers un plan d'extinction
progressive des niches fiscales néfastes
au climat qui secret de dégager 4,1
milliard d'euros dès 2024 et jusqu'à 8,3
milliards d'euros en 2027 une écho
contribution sur les billets d'avion
tels que la convention citoyenne pour le
climat vous le proposez qui rapporterait
3 milliards d'euros et une contribution
exceptionnelle sur le patrimoine des
plus riches tels que le rap bisani ferry
vous le suggérez mais hélas vous l'avez
balayé d'un revers de la main dès sa
publication celui-ci avait pourtant
chiffré des recettes potentielles de
cette contribution infiniment justifiée
au regard de l'empreinte carbone des
plus aisées à 5 milliards d'euros
annuels on peut donc très bien financer
la transition écologique la
réhabilitation de nos services publics
et répondre aux besoins sociaux d'une
population française qui s'enfonce tous
les jours un peu plus dans la précarité
tout en maintenant nos équilibres
budgétaires mais ce n'est pas le choix
que vous avez fait vous sacrifiez
l'ambition écologique et la protection
des plus vulnérables sur l'hôtel de la
sacro-sainte baisse d'impôts vous
comprendrez qu'en responsabilité les
écologistes ne pourront soutenir la
trajectoire financière de cette loi de
programmation qui est incompatible avec
le financement de la transition
écologique et de nos services publics je
conclurai en citant les experts du
dernier rapport du GIEC il faudrait
multiplier d'un facteur 3 à 6 les
ressources dont nous disposons pour
limiter l'élévation des températures à 2
degrés à l'horizon 2030 et le volume de
capitaux et de liquidité disponible à
l'échelle planétaire et suffisant pour
atteindre le montant investir tout
dépendra de la clarté des signaux que
donneront les gouvernements et la
communauté internationale notamment par
l'adoption de mesures financières et de
votre politique plus ferme voilà
Monsieur administre ce que les
écologistes attendent de votre part des
signaux plus clairs des mesures
financières et des politiques plus
fermes
c'est cela la responsabilité face au
dérèglement climatique je vous remercie
merci madame la députée pour le groupe
GDR pour 5 minutes monsieur sangsue
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
les ministres monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues après les
procès en irresponsabilité pour avoir
refusé de voter le projet de loi de
finances pour 2023 voilà qu'il faudrait
désormais à tout prix voter un projet de
loi pourtant rejeter un an auparavant au
prétexte qui nous amènerait à rembourser
plusieurs milliards d'euros de
subventions à l'Union européenne au
titre des plans nationaux de relance et
de résilience il est vrai que depuis
longtemps maintenant face à l'Europe
vous avez fait le choix d'abdiquer en
Rasque campagne comme vous êtes en train
de le faire concernant la liquidation du
service public du Fred ferroviaire cela
n'a jamais été le projet des députés de
mon groupe qui se sont depuis Maastricht
toujours opposés aux poussées néolibéral
venant de Bruxelles mais pire c'est
vous-même qui vous êtes mis dans cet
impact et il est clair que nous
pourrions revenir sur ses règles et
contrainte parce que notre pays est un
grand pays est un grand pays dans
l'Union européenne autant vous dire donc
messieurs les ministres que ce type de
pression pour l'adoption d'un texte ne
saurait avoir un quelconque effet sur
les députés de notre groupe
et à première vue c'est un attelage
curieux rassemblant aux commissions la
majorité présidentielle la droite
républicaine et l'extrême droite qui a
permis l'adoption d'un texte mais en
fait ce n'est pas si étrange parce que
lorsqu'il s'agit de réduire la
protection sociale de détruire des
services publics de supprimer les impôts
des plus aisés l'alliance des droites
est toujours de sortie car c'est bien de
cela dont il s'agit avec cette loi de
programmation des finances publiques une
loi budgétaire qui malgré son caractère
non contraignant vise bien à compresser
les dépenses publiques et permettez-moi
de sourire au hiatus qui se fait jour
d'un côté vous affirmez comme ça a été
le cas en commission que ce n'est pas
contraignant et de l'autre vous nous
promettez la onzième plaie d'Égypte si
nous ne l'adoption pas la vérité c'est
bien que vous souhaitez corseter les
projets de loi de finance à venir et ne
pas laisser au Parlement la possibilité
de faire des choix différents de ceux
des canons libéraux et à vous écouter
messieurs les ministres on ne comprend
pas la gratitude de nos concitoyens
devant des résultats que vous estimez
toujours flamboyant
mais vous oubliez c'est vrai la pauvreté
qui explose vous oubliez que 40% des
familles modestes disent ne pas pouvoir
faire trois repas par jour vous oubliez
aussi les étudiants qui font la queue
devant les associations caritatives pour
manger jamais je dis bien jamais même au
pic de l'austérité durant ce qu'on a
appelé la crise des dettes souveraines
une si faible croissance en volume des
dépenses publiques n'aura été inscrite
c'est donc bien de l'austérité que vous
instaurez d'autant une austérité
d'autant plus dure qu'il y a des
dépenses contraintes par les lois de
programmation c'est le cas pour les
dépenses de police de justice de de
défense ou pour la recherche et
finalement pour 40% du périmètre total
des dépenses puisque celle-ci sont
aujourd'hui cadrées par ces lois de
programmation spécifique la Cour des
comptes a d'ailleurs chiffré ce
supplément de dépenses déjà prévu à 5 à
6 milliards d'euros dans ces conditions
ou donc vous cherchez les nouvelles
économies pour atteindre vos objectifs
le ministre s'est déjà félicité d'avoir
effectuer des milliards d'euros
d'économie sur le dos des chômeurs et il
s'apprête à le faire encore avec la loi
qui t’en discussion avec la réforme des
retraites on devrait là aussi approcher
10 milliards d'euros d'économie jusqu'où
irez-vous dans la destruction de notre
système de protection sociale l'hôpital
public est d'ores et déjà aux abois les
urgences ferment la nuit certains
weekends et ce partout en France et dans
les outre-mer pourtant la croissance de
l'ONDAM reste à peine au-dessus de
l'inflation et ne permettra pas de
répondre aux défis du vieillissement et
des besoins de santé que dire aussi des
collectivités territoriales que vous ne
cessez de mépriser comme vous l'avez
montré lors de votre obstruction sur
notre proposition de loi pour indexer la
DGF sur l'inflation nos collectivités
sont assommées par l'envolée des prix de
l'énergie heureusement messieurs les
ministres le futur 49-3 ne devrait pas
réintégrer l'article 16 refusé un
commission puisque vous avez dit que
vous partiez du texte de la commission
la chasse aux économies à laquelle vous
vous livrez ne conduira et vous le savez
qu'à poursuivre la destruction de nos
services publics et de notre pacte
social un autre chemin est pourtant
possible celui qui fait participer
chaque contribuable à sa juste
proportion selon l'article 13 de la
Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme et du
Citoyen j'ai rendu hier un rapport sur
la fiscalité du patrimoine avec mon
collègue Mattei les alternatives à votre
politique mortifère existe contribution
des hauts revenus hausse de l'imposition
des revenus du capital encadrement des
déposes fiscales oui messieurs les
ministres il faut changer l'architecture
fiscale pour retrouver de la
progressivité et de la justice enfin
comment ne pas terminer par la blessure
démocratique que constitue le 49-3 sur
ce premier texte moi monsieur monsieur
les ministres débutez notre session
ainsi et irresponsable et au gurmal de
la suite de la véracité du respect du
Parlement et de la démocratie nous
ventrons bien sûr entendu contre ce
projet de loi bien entendu si nous en
avons l'occasion ce dont je doute
merci pour le groupe pilote monsieur de
Courson
monsieur le Président Monsieur des
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances je le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues
le texte que nous étudions cette nuit
est une programmation bancale à
plusieurs titres
d'abord
personnel nous de considérer vos
hypothèses économiques comme irréalistes
ou comme le dit le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques optimiste moi je
dirais même très optimiste vous estimez
que la croissance avec un taux de 1,35
en moyenne période sera portée par la
hausse de l'investissement la baisse du
taux d'épargne des ménages et la hausse
du taux d'activité mais monsieur les
ministres le premier facteur est
hasardeux puisque les taux d'intérêt
remontent et pénalise l'investissement
le second est très aléatoire car ce qui
importe n'est pas le taux d'épargne brut
mais le taux d'épargne net des
remboursements d'emprunt or les ménages
se sont beaucoup endettés à l'époque où
les taux d'intérêt étaient très bas et
donc on assiste à une augmentation des
remboursements des ménages donc ce qui
importe c'est le taux d'épargne net
c'est-à-dire l'épargne disponible qui
peut s'investir dans des investissements
divers et variés ou rester d'ailleurs
liquide comme hélas on le constate
beaucoup
et puis le troisième critère est loin
d'être confirmé puisque depuis 2017 le
taux de chômage de catégorie a diminué
de 9% à 7%, mais la Banque de France
prévoit une remontée du taux de chômage
en 2024
car la vraie et la grande question c'est
pourquoi
la productivité apparente du travail
baisse
quelles en sont les facteurs ils ne se
sont pas suffisamment analysés et
traiter car s'il y a une baisse de la
productivité apparente du travail
il est évident que il y aura moins de
richesses à partager et que tout votre
schéma messieurs les ministres
s'effondre enfin vos dernières
prévisions
semblent ne pas tenir compte de la
remontée très rapide des cours de
pétrole qui est passé de 80 dollars le
baril en juillet dernier à plus de 90 93
95 actuellement mais du fait d'une
stratégie de l'Arabie Saoudite et de la
Russie de réduire la production et donc
s'il maintienne une telle stratégie
pendant quelques années ceci va être un
prélèvement sur le pouvoir d'achat des
pays consommateurs de pétrole
en second lieu
nous ne partageons pas votre analyse sur
les conséquences en matière d'aide
européenne
en cas d'un éventuel rejet vous ne dites
que vous entendez respecter vos
engagements vis-à-vis de la Commission
et ainsi éviter de faire peser un risque
financier sur notre pays mais première
question est-ce que vous avez été
couvert par le Parlement avant de vous
engager sur plus d'une centaine de
jalons comme vous les appelez dont
celui-là et donc l'argument juridique
selon lequel le premier le prochain
versement du Fonds relan européen
pourrait être supprimé est inexact nous
avons une note de la commission des
finances qui dit que peut-être mais
peut-être pas à Rio ce qui est certain
c'est qu'avec un déficit structurel de
4,2% du PIB fin 2022 et de 4,1% en 2023
notre crédibilité budgétaire
et très affaibli et nous serions
concernés dès le printemps prochain par
l'activation de la procédure européenne
pour déficit excessif c'est ça ce qui
nous pend on est et qui est une loi de
programmation ou pas de loi de
programmation mais sur les ministres
plutôt que de vouloir nous convaincre de
voter une programmation qui ne nous
convient pas mais accélérer la
trajectoire de réduction des déficits
nous vrons alors votre loi de
programmation répondant alors à votre
menace sur le plan de relance européen
et au risque plus réel de la sanction
pour déficit excessif les députés iode
sont profondément pro-européens mais en
aucun cas nous utiliserons l'Europe
comme menace pour convaincre
qu'on contraindre le débat démocratique
national nous pensons et qu'il est
encore possible que la France respecte
les critères budgétaires de Bruxelles
tout en restant un pays souverain et
puis le troisième point concerne la
dette
je pourrais vous décerner monsieur le
ministre la médaille des 3000 milliards
de dettes publiques je pourrais adresser
à votre jeune collègue
la médaille des 700 milliards pendant
les six années pendant lesquelles vous
avez géré
et bien
je le ferai peut-être un jour et
oui j'ai encore j'ai presque fini non
non c'est fini et donc la dette merci
monsieur le député la preuve de votre
échec merci
contre ce texte
bien 5 minutes avec le groupe
Renaissance monsieur Lefebvre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres qui ne sont pas des jeunes
ministres médés ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général je
voudrais profiter du temps qui m'est
imparti pour tenter de vous convaincre
cher parti chers collègues des parties
gouvernement chers collègues qui avait
l'intérêt supérieur de la nation je
crois et je l'espère encore chevillé au
corps que nous avons besoin d'une loi de
programmation au-delà de la trajectoire
elle-même j'ai entendu ce que vous avez
dit madame la Présidente rabot j'aurais
m’adresser à vous parce que c'est vous
qui avez traduit dans notre droit
interne d'abord avec le président
Sarkozy en 2008 cet outil et ensuite
dans notre droit organique avec le
président Hollande en 2012 et je crois
qu'il faut le dire sans chercher à
responsabiliser ou à culpabiliser qui
compte parce que au fond vous savez très
bien vous-même que nous avons besoin
d'une loi de programmation nous en avons
pour quatre raisons au moins nous avons
besoin pour quatre raisons tout d'abord
par rapport à quand même parce qu'une
loi de programmation c'est un instrument
de contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
de la part du Parlement on a en
commission adopté des amendements de
tout bord en amendement de Philippe Brun
qui limite les dépenses fiscales et nous
en avons assisté tout à l'heure à une
motion de rejet pour éviter le débat sur
ce texte mais enfin chers collègues
socialiste ne fait plus d'amendements si
c'est pour refuser à la fin les textes
que vous voulez dans les caisses pour
lesquelles vous voulez qu'il y ait ces
amendements ça n'a aucun sens ce texte
propose des outils de contrôle du
Parlement qui sont essentiels et que
vous appelez de vos vœux ce texte limite
les dépenses fiscales et sociales vous
ne cessez d'en parler il le fait ce
texte évalue la qualité de l'action
publique vous en rêvez il le fait ce
texte par ailleurs permet ce texte
permet de nombreuses avancées en faveur
du Parlement notamment sur l'évaluation
des aides aux entreprises vous ne cessez
nous dire que les aides aux entreprises
doivent être évaluées c'est ce que
prévoit cette loi de programmation des
finances publiques et deuxième c'est
évidemment un enjeu de crédibilité au
niveau européen on ne peut pas vouloir
que notre pays réforme les règles
budgétaires européennes et l'affaiblir
toujours plus pour arriver en position
de négociation dans lesquelles il serait
incapable de pouvoir négocier ses règles
européennes et puis au-delà de ça ce
texte il emporte des conséquences
financières extrêmement concrètes je
reviendrai pas sur le débat sur les 18
milliards d'euros le fait avec si nous
ne votons pas ce texte nous n'aurons pas
ces 18 milliards d'euros et donc ceux
qui sont attachés au désendettement ceux
qui sont attachés à l'équilibre
budgétaire doivent nous dire très
concrètement par quel économie a du
concurrence il compte compenser ses 18
milliards d'euros sinon ça n'est pas un
débat équitable entre la majorité et les
oppositions
enfin mes chers collègues
mes chers collègues quand je pensais à
partir du gouvernement monsieur Tanguy
je pensais pas à vous rassurez-vous mes
chers collègues je crois qu'on doit
cesser de se cacher derrière les ennemis
de l'extérieur ce qui nous disent on
fait tout ça par rapport à Bruxelles on
fait tout ça par rapport au marché la
vérité c'est qu'on fait tout ça par
rapport à nous-même parce que ça fait
maintenant 40 ans qu'on dépense plus que
ce qu'on gagne et ça n'est pas moi qui
disait c'était Mendès France une nation
dans les comptes sont en désordre est
une nation qui s'abandonne mes chers
collègues mais si vous acceptez que l'on
puisse à l'horizon 2027 des pensées plus
pour rembourser nos créanciers que pour
assurer l'investissement en faveur de
l'avenir de nos enfants ça vous regarde
mais ça n'est pas la politique que nous
avons choisi de mener
pour toutes ces raisons mes chers
collègues évidemment nous allons voter
cette loi de programmation et je vous le
dis avec avec beaucoup de raisons et de
sérénité
il y a la trajectoire et l'outils aussi
la politique économique madame rabot et
cette politique budgétaire elle a permis
d'obtenir des résultats économiques sans
précédent depuis des années je les redis
ici parce que je trouve qu'on ne les dit
pas encore assez 2 millions d'emplois
créés depuis 2017 dont 300 000 emplois
industriels 300 entreprises recréées sur
notre territoire national depuis 2017
pays le plus attractif de la zone euro
depuis quatre ans désormais tous ces
résultats nous les devons à une
politique économique et budgétaire
constante qui refuse le double écueil de
la fatalité et de l'endettement je vous
remercie
merci et dernier intervenant de la
discussion générale madame Emmanuel
Ménard
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues
vous nous avez prévenu en commission
monsieur le ministre la France pourrait
perdre des milliards d'euros de fonds
alloués par l'Union européenne si nous
n'approuvons pas la loi de programmation
des finances publiques pas moins d'une
dizaine de milliards d'euros de fonds
européens en 2023 et 8 milliards en 2024
soit 18 milliards d'euros d'aide
nécessaire pour nos finances publiques
ce n'est pas rien
pour ne pas perdre ses précieuses
subsides votre projet prévoit un
désendêtement graduel d'une estimation
qui passerait cette année de 4,9% du PIB
à 2,7% en 2027 mais pas de chance le
Haut Conseil des finances publiques
organes indépendant rattaché à la Cour
des comptes vient de rendre son verdict
il estime que vos prévisions économiques
sont un peu trop optimistes et que votre
projet manque singulièrement d'ambition
en comparaison avec d'autres pays de
l'Union européenne
en effet le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques adressait la longue liste de
vos hypothèses optimistes c'est la même
que vous avez avancée pour démontrer que
vous alliez parvenir à réduire le
déficit et la dette la presse a parlé
d'un avis saignant rien que cela vous
vous êtes en effet engagé monsieur le
ministre à faire diminuer notre déficit
jusqu'à 2,7% en 2027 contre 2,9% dans la
version précédente retoquée par notre
Parlement à l'automne 2022 par 309 voix
contre 243 et a ramené la dette à 108%
du PIB contre 111,8% fin 2022 mais pour
ce faire les estimations de croissance
retenues par votre gouvernement sont
jugés bien trop optimistes votre
prévision de croissance pour 2024 même
réviser en baisse de 1,6 à 1,4% et jugé
particulièrement haute car vous rappelez
que la Banque de France table elle non
seulement sur 0,9% de croissance pour
l'année à venir quand la plupart des
économistes penchent plutôt pour
0,8%. pour 2025 vous espérez un taux de
croissance de
1,7%. alors qu'un tel taux supposerait à
la fois un fort investissement des
entreprises et un recul de l'épargne des
ménages sauf que les Français et les
derniers chiffres de l'épargne viennent
de le confirmer ont une fâcheuse
tendance à miser sur le livret A et à
reconstituer leur Madeleine depuis la
crise sanitaire par ailleurs et compte
tenu de votre refus d'augmenter les
impôts décisions que je salue car je
rappelle que la France occupe la
deuxième place des pays les plus taxés
au monde votre projet de loi de
programmation de finances publiques pour
atteindre ses objectifs va nécessiter
des économies budgétaires sans précédent
car une fois tenu compte de l'inflation
les dépenses publiques ne vont pas
pouvoir augmenter ou à peine avec une
progression allons limiter à 0,1% en
moyenne par an hors charge d'intérêt un
effort bien plus important que par le
passé et pour limiter ses dépenses vous
allez devoir procéder à d'importantes
économistes structurelles dont nous ne
savons rien puisque vous les avez
renvoyés aux revues de dépenses qui
représenteront 12 milliards d'économies
pérennes par an à partir de 2025 mais où
allez-vous donc prendre ces 12 milliards
je serai et les Français avec moi je
l'imagine bien curieuse de la prendre
et comble de malchance vous devez faire
avec la forte remontée des taux
d'intérêts auxquels on traite la France
supérieure à ce qui était espérée en
2022 avec comme conséquent immédiate un
coup de la dette qui explose bref le
Haut conseil n'est pas dupe de vos
engagements qui n'engagent que vous-même
son président Pierre Moscovici explique
d'ailleurs que depuis que les lois de
programmation des finances publiques
sont apparues en 2008 la situation des
finances publiques françaises c'est
nettement détérioré contrairement aux
objectifs aux objectifs affichés avec
constance par les lois de programmation
des objectifs non contraignants
expliquent-ils reposant sur des
hypothèses généralement optimistes et
rapidement obsolète alors on se demande
bien à quoi rime cet exercice c'est
notre intérêt collectif de montrer la
crédibilité de nos dépenses et de nos
recettes à nos compatriotes à nos
partenaires européens et accessoirement
au marché qui nous permettent de lever
l'argent dont nous avons besoin pour
financer notre dette avez-vous affirmé
monsieur le ministre pour faire court
c'est une loi d'affichage et rien de
plus un projet de loi dans lequel on
inscrit des objectifs que vous savez
très bien de pas pouvoir respecter mais
qui conditionne des milliards d'euros à
louer par l'Union européenne le tout
couronné d'un probable recours à
l'article 49-3 c'est ce que j'appelle un
jeu de dupe je vous remercie merci
madame la députée la discussion générale
est close et je vais suspendre la séance
pour deux minutes
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous la séance est reprise la
parole est à madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances monsieur le rapporteur
général du budget Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs
les députés
le projet doit programmation des
finances publiques est un texte de
responsabilité
responsabilité pour notre souveraineté
les déficits et la dette menacent
l'avenir des jeunes générations
accroissent notre dépendance et
réduisent nos marges de manœuvre
maîtriser nos finances publiques c'est
un gage de souveraineté
pour réussir nous avons besoin
d'objectifs assortis d'un calendrier
c'est précisément ce que permet ce texte
avec une trajectoire crédible pour
baisser le déficit public à 2,7% d'ici
2027 une trajectoire plus ambitieuse que
celle que nous avions prévues
initialement et dont vous aviez débattu
en première lecture
ce projet de loi c'est aussi un texte de
responsabilité
allez s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
madame la Première ministre allez-y s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
ce projet de loi c'est aussi un texte de
responsabilité vis-à-vis des Français à
qui nous devons de la clarté sur notre
trajectoire budgétaire et sur les
engagements que nous prenons
[Applaudissements]
il permet de concilier les baisses
d'impôts pour les entreprises et les
ménages et la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques
ce projet de loi c'est un texte de
responsabilité face aux grands défis
devant nous notamment la transition
écologique il prend des engagements
fermes en fixant un objectif ambitieux
de réduction de nos dépenses brunes par
rapport à nos dépenses vertes c'est une
démonstration supplémentaire de notre
volonté d'agir et la garantie que la
planification écologique disposera des
moyens nécessaires
ce projet de loi enfin c'est la
responsabilité vis-à-vis de nos
engagements européens un gage de
crédibilité vis-à-vis de nos partenaires
de la zone euro et une condition pour
obtenir 18 milliards d'euros du plan de
relance de l'Union européenne
ces 18 milliards nous en avons besoin
pour protéger les Français face à
l'inflation pour avancer vers le plein
emploi pour mener la transition
écologique pour améliorer nos services
publics pour assurer l'ordre républicain
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
mesdames et messieurs les députés la
discussion sur ce texte a commencé il y
a 14 mois
cette année n'a pas été vaine nous avons
pu faire évoluer le projet de loi et
nous avons tenté à nouveau et comme
toujours de trouver des points d'accord
avec les oppositions
cette semaine un vote a eu lieu en
commission et le texte a été adopté
mais après avoir écouté les uns et les
autres je constate qu'au-delà de la
majorité présidentielle aucun groupe
n'est prêt à voter ce texte essentiel
pour notre pays
ce projet de loi a déjà été rejeté en
première lecture nous avons besoin de
cette loi de programmation de nos
finances publiques nous ne pouvons pas
prendre le moindre risque aussi sur le
fondement de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre pas de claquement de petites
monsieur Tanguy l'Assemblée nationale
prend acte de l'engagement de la
responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément au disposition de l'article
49 à Linéa 3 de la Constitution le texte
sur lequel la première ministre engage
la responsabilité du gouvernement sera
insérée en annexe au compte-rendu de la
présence séance en application de
l'article 155 alinéa premier du
règlement le débat sur ce texte est
immédiatement suspendu ce texte sera
considéré comme adopté sauf si une
motion de censure déposée avant demain
23h58 et votez dans les conditions
prévues à l'article 49 de la
Constitution dans l'hypothèse ou une
motion de censure serait déposée la
Conférence des Présidents fixera la date
et les modalités de sa discussion
prochaine séance demain à 9h suite du
projet de loi pour le plein emploi la
séance est levée